[Applause]
dude it's so crazy how
it feels like forever it does seem like
one week is so long
in front of me and i love mondays
because like i have such a good weekend
like we don't do anything saturday
sunday so like during saturday and
sundays we just like lay by the pool and
eat so much food and i just like love it
let's go
you know something interesting over the
weekend no we literally just sit by the
pool and order food like what did you
eat i don't know
we mean well we always do the same we
have fried chicken and mashed potatoes
for lunch and then we do a big ziti at
sunday night
and then we have burgers in quesadillas
on saturday
monday through friday we do the
intermittent fasting the one meal but we
do go off on
on the weekends and it was really good
but oh dude
say that again for me let me just you
don't even like the food i like say the
food you don't like fried chicken
love fried chicken mashed potatoes love
mashed potatoes big ziti i know you
don't like it
whatever i'll eat it hamburgers yes
arby's curly fries
but you go to arby's and just get the
curly no the frozen we put them in the
airfryer
you can buy frozen orbeez yes they're
delicious let's go
there's nothing good keep going
quesadillas oh chicken quesadillas those
are really bomb
we got bavarian cream we always have a
little hummus and potatoes
drink you always show too oh well this
is a new one this is this one we
we saw someone at starbucks ordering we
just didn't know what it was we're like
we'll take that it looked good it looked
cooler earlier
there's no label on this oh what the
[ __ ]
it's our label it's a white mocha which
we freak and caramel dress i know i was
like dude you're living your best life
no no but we are
we are sweating for the wedding
seriously moses like you know we both
were like we need to like get it into
gear for the wedding
um because i'm so jealous i i just you
look great you look better though thank
you
they say nothing tastes as good as
skinny feels
oh they say that yeah have you heard
that who said that no but i like it yeah
we can't believe that's a really good
saying i think it was good chaos one of
those 90s supermodels we debate that
though because food tastes really good
yeah
i don't agree i feel like we could
debate this but i've never been skinny
so i don't know you've been you've been
skinny you know you're skinny now
when i was skinny i didn't appreciate it
because i was born skinny he became fat
oh i was born fat born fat yeah
you were 12 pound baby yeah as a
telephone baby you were born fat
i was always bad i'm just a fat fat
fatty i'm inside no i'm in a good mood
i'm going to give
last you guys in a bad mood i don't know
we were talking and i i don't know if
you felt my negative energy but
oh yeah we had a treasure had kind of a
beef over the weekend with you
that day i was in such a bad mood when
moses tried to take me to my favorite
place to get like buttered pasta and i
was like so pissed
i don't even want to eat don't talk to
me i was trying to she was pissed at me
well it was whatever yeah it's not worth
getting into but we're good now
clearly i'm just like happy i'm just not
gonna
you know everything's positive today
like you know bring out whoever
i'll just say they're hot they're good
looking they deserve the second third
fourth
twenty one tristana 2021 this is may
2021 trisha oh
this is june 21 to 20 like happening now
like i'm getting here
yeah because it's gay pride month next
week we're gonna celebrate we should do
gay pride cause it's gonna be june first
our next friend of means we should dress
up a gay pride
uh forgive me if this is rude but are
you are you gay
i'm in the lgbtq plus you are yeah
because you're non-binary i'm non-binary
and bisexual and all of them all loving
it right you're bisexual
yeah i'm bisexual i'm not everything i
think i'm more pansexual now that i'm
looking into sexualities i do think i'm
wearing pants actually
you just you love you love you love
everybody in anything yeah because you
know but you have women and men
bisexuals women and male what's left to
love
i mean there's other there's other
genders oh there's none gender
forgive me i'm just i'm ignorant and i'm
trying i'm trying to understand oh we
have sponsors sponsors
video is uh honey and omaze thank you
honey animates for sponsoring but
so you have men and women and then
there's like trans people
well trans i would consider men and
women uh there's not but yeah right
there but there there is the
no gender there's a gender there's not
binding
what you're attracted to you know some
people don't want to have a gender some
people you know it's just like that it's
you know
so yeah i am but you know you could be
an ally if you don't consider yourself
an lgbtq plus a like you could be an
ally
i'm an ally target has an allies shirt
which a lot of people are [ __ ] on
and i get it like target's not really
with the gay pro you know they are with
it but they don't really understand like
what's cool but they have an ally shirt
and i thought it was really cool
because you know you want support of
everybody i'm an ally i'll go to war
with whoever you guys want you tell me
no we're not going to war it's lovely
i'm ready to go for war bro no no we're
lobbying my musket i'm an ally no no
it's getting gay pride is my favorite
month i even bought a gay pride burke
and do you want to i'm not i'm not
i'm uh do you want me to yeah not the
axis of evil which is straight white men
right
axis of evil i don't know i've never
heard of that no but i bought a world
war ii analogy
can i i'll bring it next week because i
have an unboxing i was going to wait
till gay pride this is the brook and i
just bought
oh it's a gay pride birkin was that the
one that you were saying 200
no this is this is the price right there
right there the second one
oh okay it's not bad can i say it let me
say it
no come on that was saying i showed the
price of my wedding dress and everyone's
like oh that's tacky don't how much was
your wedding dress
i don't want to say it what do you mean
tacky that's your brand your brand is
that's not what's that people argue
though
tell me the price i talk about price
don't say anything okay it's like 48
000.
48 000. yeah send the picture to danny
oh yeah yeah
and my wedding dress was 2000 more than
that
50 grand yeah it's gorgeous because
you're living your best life you're
eating
chicken quesadillas you're eating fried
chicken you're spending fifty thousand
dollars in wedding dress you know what
and it's taking me a long time to get
here you know what i'm saying i haven't
been miserable my like my entire life
it's crazy so you know whatever it's
happening and life's happening speaking
of getting the bag
uh literally let's pay for that bag
sad boy came from okay
you know what i mean that's like my fun
money oh all the money i send you spend
money it's a lot of fun money
i've already spent it we spent it all
like that was spent on everything
already
all right i was like let's go shopping
okay so holy [ __ ]
that's okay so okay yeah so by the way
who built your website it's pretty epic
yeah i have a really okay sadboy2005.com
yeah we have we have
we launched okay this is just phase one
but once this is gone it's sold out
and let me tell you didn't something
already sell out yeah your shirt you're
wearing now the bunny shirt
oh how come it doesn't say sold out or
you can click on it maybe
try and order like um size oh j oh
yeah it's all sold out oh my god wait
shows everything else sold out no no
just that one because i've been getting
notifications
like it was crazy we had like 400 people
waiting there at 10 a.m
i don't know what this shirt is so funny
to me favorite this is
it's literally just a picture of trisha
with like paper clips and [ __ ] it's
awesome i'm fine we're like bantees you
know what i mean like
i want this one i'll get it i'll give
you all of them
wait let me see oh i did edit so there
is some so anyway guys head on over to
trisha or
sadboy2005 dot com we did this is our
collab this is our first club we have
four more collabs coming out this year
and then we're gonna do our own in-house
stuff
i'm sorry daddy fresh is definitely an
inspiration when i i've always wanted to
do like
a clothing line but i never saw anyone
do it and then not that it's easy but
like seeing you guys do it i was like
this could be like attainable you know
what i mean and go for it
you know i feel like i don't know
anyways i'm really excited i feel like
the quality is good everything's hand
stitched
hand printed hand like this is hand dyed
this is hand sprayed on yeah
they dye this there's some dude
now they're my song brands and you know
you don't know how i collab with this
designer i like bought their stuff early
like like last year and they always like
reached out to me and i was like
and they designed all this cool sad boy
stuff and it's even moses's shirt the
one see if they're the
violets and roses one it comes with the
safety pins already in it it's
so dumb it's so cool i love that anyways
it's yeah this bunny she's already sold
out like so get on over to
and sadboy2005.com up your sad boys i
know you love these big boy shorts and i
think they're big boys
xl too small i mean yeah too small
i swear to god you want me to try them
right now my fat ass will not fit into
those
for all the talk you say about how
skinny i am do you know do you see the
tags too because i know like teddy fresh
has their own tags i'm like oh i don't
even do my own taste you guys are
inspired
well oh my god you're turning oh you're
going off camera okay oh you have boxers
i was like oh my god are you going off
camera yes those fit
they're a little tight but they do fit
yeah is that your skin oh my god
okay oh look at that okay skinny
lipsticks
you look so good i know what you're
saying but they look really nice i think
they look good i can get a double xl for
you these are so cool
these are hand bleached hand stitched
patch everything is these are nice
yeah yeah they're really cute thank you
i know you like the gym shorts i got you
the gym shorts too and then they're a
little
tight so you have my thumb yeah yeah
yeah yeah first you're like okay okay
but i forgot i forgot you're a little
hippie and i love that i'm a little
hippie
this is a 2xl and this is an xl but i
know you say you wear excel so i got you
exile so that's why i look like i'm
swimming in my shirt but maybe
trisha is going a billion miles a second
today
and then we have bucket hats coming june
14th so there'll be a second phase
[ __ ] hack
once it's gone it's gone this is it
folks yeah but we have we have a second
phase and then um yeah then there's
other i want this one
like i'll get i'll go
you know it wasn't my idea to put my
face on it because i wanted to be very
like teddy fresh where it's a different
thing than me you know it's not just
trisha paytas like you're the sad boy
um no everyone's a little sad boy inside
you know what i mean oh
for sure so it's a myspace page it's
really cool um the video is out on my on
my youtube channel
it's like alcohol i i put coin into this
i bought a trans am for this video
before you could spray paint it like i
put coin into it you know what i mean
like my profit off this will be very
little because i put so much money into
like the video but i love doing it so
who cares
can i wait can you show the video oh my
god video or do you wanna
okay no no i'll show the video it's on
your youtube page just like put so much
into this like this is she like this all
day
she's been like this all day i'm manic
but i'm a manikai today so that's good
you know i'm like
oh yeah feeling good we love feeling
good trisha paytas
uh which channel just trisha betas just
typing you know that's all you gotta do
there it is the first one bad boy oh i'm
so excited it's a short it's like a
minute it's not a
music video next week is a full music
video though coming soon okay okay here
we go
it won't copyright my own copyright i'm
gonna [ __ ] sue you for copyright
wait wait a minute remind us what did i
do i'm watching the whole thing it's
just you guys walking around your
hoodies
no it's our it's first off our apparel
okay
do you have a stunt driver yeah
this is where my chemical romance shot
uh i know exactly where
it's funny everyone goes out to this
location and does videos well mcr did
their video with their trans am here
which is why we did it
was that your sis that's my sis um
that's my band
and those are models stella is like
blown up right now she's like really big
on youtube and stuff
we found stella because she bought my
first bad boy merch and she looked
dope in it so i was like yes and then um
yeah they were they were great all the
models are really good
where's the guy where's the fat guy i
mean where's the representation of fat
man
you wanna be where's the fat men with
the
too tight shirt and their guts and
they're supposed to seriously i
considered myself to be the plus size
okay all right nice work around
well you know i try to be you know i'm
complaining
that there's not equal representation i
need fat men
i consider myself p sometimes so i do
identify as he said
[Music]
all right wait wait wait no there's
literally 20 seconds i spent so much
money that's like
okay yeah yeah that's fine yeah
and if anybody wants to buy that trans
am we had a custom painted sad boy but
if we had a car
yeah it was a bad idea everything will
be cousin
how much for the car it won't pass the
smack jack i don't know someone email me
i always get someone emails if someone
wants to help me
anything else you're selling you want to
put out there tradio what else do you
got for sale oh i told you we have more
coming in the next few weeks but
it's summer baby it's qvc here in front
of me we're gonna just be come on now we
gotta use
tumble copy use double copper going for
five dollars five dollars five dollars
everyone is very stressed that
everything's gonna sell out of front of
me i know front of me just coming you
guys that's coming
like a month so you can buy sad boy in
the meantime buy sad boy as the
appetizer to freddie means and then you
can just wear ow
oh my god okay okay all right all right
soundboardtestingby.com thank you we
already saw
this you want to see what my promo looks
like and here's my promo
you don't need promo okay hang on hang
on here's my promo compared to trish's
okay ready here we go new teddy fresh
is out the new color block is out
2.0 remastered oh no those are dope
though that pink and orange and yellow
that's dope as [ __ ] like that's that's
cool
thank you here's just some pictures to
appetize you go to teddyfresh.com
no these are dope as hell this jacket
already sold out but yeah
sold out yeah it sold out like an hour
it was kind of damn
these are all sold out too yeah this is
like elevated level you know what can i
say an anecdote
me and ela went to target yesterday and
some girl came up to ela
who didn't know who we were and ila was
wearing this jacket and she's like
where who made that jacket oh yeah oh
yeah i believe that oh
cool like that's never happened we see
people all the time and teddy fresh like
we were shopping at three people and
you're supposed to wear free people when
you work at free people and the girl was
wearing teddy fresh
she's a free person that's the
definition of a real free person well
she kind of freaked out when she saw us
and then
and then moses it was an old teddy fresh
she's like that's like an original teddy
fresh thing it was so weird
i designed this shirt by the way
inspired by post malone
oh i love that yeah what is it a polar
bear polar bear with like the tongue i
love that it kind of looks like a golden
retriever too so i was like torn
you guys have bags now bags toast yada
yada go to teddyfish.com i love the
styles yeah
ultimately i want sad boy to be like
2005 trends you know like flares like
tube tops like i like how you guys are
going different than just t-shirts and
hoodies and that's like
where i want to be i'm like here and i
want to be here but you guys took all
you know so i'll get there you know i'll
be like there too one day but it'll be
different you know we'll be like
not that you're threatening but you know
like platform sandals like little
sunglasses like i'm gonna take you out
i'm gonna take your [ __ ] sad boy out
dude
i'm gonna have to like do a hostile
takeover of sad boy
well no ours is like you know 2005 but
you know it's just you just inspired me
i was like okay they can do it like we
can you know what i mean and we go
our offices we're gonna get every i just
want an office to be honest i'm like
let's build office oh my god
work there but how long have she been
like this
i've been up holy [ __ ] i want that
energy i wish i could bottle that energy
and drink it in the morning the show
producer had the audacity to be i was i
gave her 30 minutes
you can't give me 30 more minutes i'm
like [ __ ] i need i have fashion oh i
got adam and eve i got friend of mine i
got all this [ __ ] i got 30 minutes of
trisha right now with like 10 hours how
much more time do you need she's
like light and fast i was just doing the
most and then tomorrow we have
30 minutes yeah i get about 5 a.m to
glam tomorrow we have friend of mine i
had to get that costume around i have so
much happening so
i didn't get to film i didn't do tick
tocks this morning i didn't even do tick
tocks that's how freaking
unforgivable we got to do that booty
tic-tac-toe
okay so so um can we talk about dear
evan hansen is that on the list or no
who dear evan hansen ben platt did you
hear that scandal there haven't ha
you're talking so fast with the words
there haven't had to be did you hear
about it no who is that okay ben platt
being too old to play evan hansen you
haven't heard this you know broadway
dear evan hansen
you've never heard of hanson you've
never heard of your heaven handsome
never have i answered no i don't know
who that is
no the movie the trailer is this dear
heaven hansen
just slow down and explain yourself do
you know ben platt
here do you know who ben platt is no
ben platt i don't even know why we do
this show together honestly that
producer oh i know blind player no yeah
i know i know ben platt what's he been
in he's made this
he made the netflix thing that i really
liked about he's the politician the
politician
what's it called the politician okay
okay okay okay but
the producer asked me today like why do
you do front of me with ethan i'm like i
don't know he doesn't
know who asked you that question the
[ __ ] after that
our reality show pretty much that way
but you don't even know there's
a girl who's been trying to pitch us
this reality show i love her
she's trying to get me to sign a talent
hold which i'm close to but i feel like
what else are we doing
no nothing but i feel like we can make
our own reality show okay we can but
it's also kind of nice how someone just
like do this stuff for you all you know
what i mean like
yeah but then i don't like giving people
editorial because then you have to sign
some [ __ ] and she goes i don't think
that's funny i'm like [ __ ] this is
funny
sorry for the b word no one says we're
not funny who says we're not going to
know what i'm saying when you get into
this creative talks with executives and
stuff
they have creative control like oh no
you should be doing this we're going to
have to cut that out and reshoot it and
do it this way
no i'll be like no okay anyways
did you see it all right did you see
this controversy
dear evan hansen is a broadway tony
award he won the tony award for director
heaven hansen what does dear heaven
handle dear evan hansen
it's complicated say it slow because i
don't know what you're saying
okay i swear you okay dear really i
wanted to talk about this this is the
only thing i want to talk about
who's dear evan hansen okay it's a
broadway show have you seen that poster
ever no you never saw that post
and it has been platinum ben platt
started he won the tony for it like one
so keep that in mind
i'm kidding stupid he won the tony award
i can't wait till we go to broadway
would you do the show in new york with
me
like will you fly or i have to fly here
everywhere you want me to perform or
watch it no
our podcast how are we going to do the
podcast when i'm on broadway are you
going to come to new york or do you have
a library
figure it out don't worry do you want to
come to new york yes okay when you're
starring in your own broadway show it's
not my own broadway show probably like
chicago or wicked or something already
established
well you should fly here what the [ __ ] i
got that but i have to be on vocal rest
monday so i can't really be traveling
because it's not good for me okay girl
you go
you got to figure it out okay all right
so this show's
the trailer came out last week just tell
me what it is
well i can't explain to you what it is
like it's complicated it's about this
guy who has no friends evan right evan's
kind of what is the asperger's artistic
he's kind of something on the on the
spectrum
so he has no friends whatever he breaks
his arm you don't really know at the
beginning of the show you don't really
know how he breaks his arm or whatever
like that
and then one of the kids signs that he's
like here let me sign it so it looks
like we both have friends and his name's
connor
comes and so as part of his therapy his
therapist says to evan write letters to
yourself to help you heal so he's
writing letters to himself
connor the guy who signs his cast finds
the letter and keeps it he's like ha ha
i'm keeping this letter whatever
and so then the next like a couple weeks
past whatever the guy that finds the
letter and signed his cast
kills himself he's suicide he's
satisfied kills himself so then the
parents go to evan and like oh his last
letter was to you even though evan wrote
it to himself
and so then he tries to like he gives
them hope he wants them to believe that
he had friends and stuff and he's trying
to like do good but then he gets caught
up in this thing saying that they're
friends but they're not friends and it
gets caught up that they were never
friends and he was just lying about it
the whole time
close to assistant so what's the drama
so the drama is the movie came out
and ben platt is starring in it ben
platt is 27 years old evan hansen is 16
years old so the drama is that he's too
old
ben platt oh but ben looks
look at the trailer with like muting it
don't put the sound on it because he
looks very different
like the trailer gave him like curly
hair so he's so people are mad that he's
too old i mean who gives a [ __ ] so they
say he's too old and this is the kicker
then so everyone's like and i'll tell
you what i'm on because i'm i'm i'm
portraying it as one way but it's not
his his dad is the executive producer
mark plattsburgh oh
nepotism exactly [ __ ]
mark platt also produced la la land he
did all those big movies you know what i
mean so
so wait ben platt's an industry plant
ben platt
plant so here's the thing is like he won
the tony though he's yeah
no he's really good in that show what
show the politicians
i thought netflix okay but you didn't
see him in evan hansen i don't know what
do you think about evan hansen he was
also on pitch perfect he was like i got
the magic he's in there so what do you
see what's your complaint
okay so they always do this in movies
they always cast people are way too
[ __ ] old do you think he looks
no no he looks he looks he doesn't look
that old i have to be honest
i'm not upset here's the thing grease
everyone's damn yeah
he looks he doesn't look like a high
school student but but
i can suspend my disbelief yeah sure
that's not fair [ __ ]
[ __ ] so what people want a six-year-old
cast oh yeah okay so that's the thing so
there's
an evan hansen that was on broadway
before quarantine has named jordan
fisher who also has like a pretty good
resume being on tv and stuff and like
why wouldn't you cast jordan fischer who
was actually like 18 or 17
instead of you know ben platt and
they're thinking because his dad
executive
you know what you know what his name
should be now ben plant
ben industries okay i like that i mean
trying to stay positive so i don't
really like you know maybe
what's his name the guy you think he
should be playing him jordan what jordan
fisher
jordan fishing for a role but he can't
get it himself he was evan hansen
before the quarantine so type him in his
he looks older than [ __ ] bad plants
you know why look at him he looks better
how old is he
i don't know actually this [ __ ]
is older i just go by tick-tock i think
i shouldn't go
with tick-tock knowledge i don't know
hang on this dude looks old
no okay 27. he's 27.
what are we arguing about trisha and
then ben
plant wait that motherfucker's old as
hell
[Music]
and ben plant looks younger um
how you know bro what just happened you
know
so you so you're on you think he's
deserving and you play the role
hold on you just ranted about how he's
too old but they're the same age
well i think ben plant looks more the
part than the other guy
well he's the originator the other guy's
like ooh i'm a suave
cruel [ __ ] yeah jordan fisher plays
cool sounds like ben plant is more
the kind of word out of place character
um yeah jordan fisher did do a good job
team ben plant
well he's the originator like if you
listen to the catholic party it's been
platt's voice do you know that song
waving through a window i try to speak
but nobody can hear so i
know around for an
nope oh oh can i say one more thing and
then we'll get off this i promise
the reason he broke his arm we find out
at the end is because he was trying to
kill him
the whole [ __ ] what's been out for
like four years okay all right
so did you hear i haven't seen it i was
probably gonna watch the movie so we
find out that actually
evan he the way he broke his arm was he
was trying to kill himself off a tree
and he ended up falling and just
breaking his arm
and in that song he says he's like he
goes and you're falling in a forest and
nosing around just do you really crash
or even make a sound if you're falling
in a force and there's no one around
does it really really crash or even make
a sound did i even make a sound did i
even make a sound
and never made a sound will i ever make
a sound we're going to get copy they're
going to strike out
close to the original game bro spoiler
alert by the way yeah we think he's
deserving yes tick tock is up in arms
about it it makes me so sad
i don't understand i'd like to get one
of their perspectives because clearly
it's not an age thing
like a theater community no but it is an
age thing that was the biggest oh is
this him dan
yeah this is my boy who needs to be in
every movie role
this is the guy that they want to play
him look at this [ __ ] are you [ __ ]
is this are you serious what is this
what's this
he's playing the flash or something yes
wait this is
real this is like his face was
photoshopped on someone else's face
why would they put this out it's just
funny because this has been going around
on twitter the last week
of this goofy-s picture that's jordan
fisher
whoa is he playing him though it's just
like a yeah he's playing him
yeah no this is real this is like why
are people hitting ben playing yeah he's
he's killing it
i don't know people you know can you
look into this because i feel like trish
is getting this right yeah
they're both the same thing what happens
they build people up like everyone was
team ben platt for so long
and now they want to tear him down
because he got the movie role it's like
this is what happens when people
sound like he's already superstars
anyone who gets liked people want to
like smash them down you know what i
mean it's just like you know
just let them live then plat some
problematic as far as i know i don't
know
let's do ben platt controversy i'm sure
he thinks i'm a troll i think i'm sure
he hates me but like
ben platt you think he knows who you are
uh yeah for sure
okay here here here i've got a buzzfeed
article i'll read it for you okay
ben platt reacts to critique of his
agent dear hanson
evan hansen and he made a good point
okay let's look at this
ben plant industry plant okay
it's not okay he played it in broadway
so the guy
i mean that sounds like a great thing
that he's playing pony for it over
beetlejuice
yeah these people need to chill bruh i
am so blah blah
he's i'm get trying to get to the point
i'm not getting to the point i'm closing
the article
oh oh greece as seen in greece so like
all the people who were in greece were
over 27 they were all like 30 you know
what i mean
but if you can actually give me the real
controversy and uh
but the other guy's the same age and he
looks older
ah i don't know but i heard that i see
it
yeah tick-tock yeah they're just over
ben plant
they just wanna well it's not too old i
mean they just wanna bring them down
they're just haters but i i support you
ben platt don't think i'm a freak
the theater world does not like me the
theater world thinks i'm creepy and
weird i'm sorry i'm i was problematic
i'm not anymore gay pride lgbtq plus
here we go next week gabe pride
frenemies can we set this up in rainbow
we're having a gay pride friend
yeah let's say let's do wait what's next
week is it pride week june 1st is the
beginning of pride month oh
well we got a whole month to celebrate
well we got to kick it off
kick it off right yeah anyways i
that was my i was so annoyed with
tick-tock i'm like what's with the aegis
thing like let them play the part you
know what i mean like
so maybe this was said and i just missed
it but from what i'm seeing
the reason people are saying this jordan
fisher guy should have played it is he
played it on broadway yeah
right right before quarantine oh cause
he they think oh you get to double dip
in your role
no that he should have been given the
role on tv it's not about the age it's
about the fact that he played it on
broadway but the way it
happened he played
what are you saying dan i'm saying that
jordan this jordan played it on broadway
i explained to you ben what is going on
no one wants to hear this
over evan you know what don't say that
i could say some really bad thing about
everything i'm already suicidal we do
not need to push that
further he's a fictional character so
with peace and love
let's just [ __ ] let's just get it
done so we can move on with this
conversation maybe next time you'll
break something more than your arm
oh so we can move he's a fictional
character
oh my god he's not real if you go and
buy the evan hansen shirt it goes to the
trevor project i bought like six of them
i did four but i meant six why'd you buy
somebody just donate to trevor i keep
losing them in my house
okay i did a lot of cosplays as evan
hansen i really love him i'm over
evan hansen he needs to shut the [ __ ] up
and just get on with it god
are you gonna see the movie it comes on
september 25th i will see the movie
because i like ben what if we get
sponsored
sponsored
by this not after i wish death on him do
you think sad boy will be in spencer's
gifts i hope so
are they still around bro okay move on
holy [ __ ] oh my god oh my gay pride
socks look at your socks
jump can
see the bear oh okay i see the bear
everywhere everyone's knocking off that
bear
yeah there are a lot of people using
bears that's crazy um i got banned on
wiki feet why
they said i was uh too much breaking
ruining the website basically you were
you kind of i love her
said anybody you kind of i listen people
upvoted me because they thought my feet
were the best if there's any other
alternative motive i never said
you have a nice feet i will say for a
guy you haven't thank you see
are you not there anymore here let's go
sight raiding you're going to love this
dan is number one [ __ ] judas oh
dan is number one little toe dan has
been so in chaos
this entire like little finger from game
of thrones i've been taken down so many
times
by myself this entire time no damn
chaos is a ladder and you know what you
use to climb ladders feet
judas good point exactly judas what is
that reference is that a biblical
reference right
do you thought you were like a christian
judas i don't really know what he did
he's the he's betrayer well what did he
do to betray him
he he ratted him out right yeah he
betrayed uh
jesus to the romans he didn't stab him
or anything though he just rattled no he
just he sniffed
the [ __ ] he's a snitch which is why
snitching is the worst ground yeah
snitches get stitches actually goes back
to the story
if there's something bad happening alert
people you can be a snitches that's part
of the
gospel jesus said snitches gets [ __ ]
[ __ ] that fool
you know what's crazy i was working with
a guy in a restaurant once in college
and um i jokingly called him judas and
he got
he like he he cut me out of his life he
never
he like never talked to me again he
wanted to like fight me and [ __ ] like we
were homies he was driving me home
and i was like ah dude like just joking
around speaking to judas who look who's
number two you always
jesus christ
yeah you're number two now moses [ __ ]
jews oh my god
none of us ever asked me by snakes
i'm surrounded by snakes not me i'm here
yeah i'm not a snake i'm a piggy oh my
god
okay what animal are you i don't know
what i am are you like a maybe
like a little a little sheep a little
bear sheep is a follower
like a little bear like old timer so
moses
uh you know again judas here
literally as jesus that's weird though
uh yeah that's like a double entendre i
don't think that works
moses says jesus is judas well i don't
know maybe jesus was his own judas
because god is everybody and everything
so god is judas
deep thank you i like that proof is here
on wiki feet
and then zach the sound soundlad is
number three and i'm nowhere to be found
it's outrageous you're gone completely
i'm gone
well okay it may have had something to
do with love who went
they loved they locked my up votes to
five points because like you can go
above five i had like a seven out of
five wow
and so what happened was um love went
with all of the
foot soldiers and down voted everyone on
the website to put him below five so i
would be number one
and i think he hacked it no he just went
there with a bunch of people and started
downvoting everybody's score to get
below five is this a new member of h3 i
don't know love
he's yeah he's going to sweden he's on
the show yeah
what's he do what does love do
he runs all of the highlights i know you
don't move on from your cast and crew
um so blah blah blah yeah yeah yeah or
they just crew
talent fees like when they're on camera
do you pay them extra
are you feeling early that doesn't
matter i don't know why i'm i was
wondering i wondered that when i was
watching the diamonds
don't you don't do any talent i'm
kidding there's oh my god
you know what though you're really
influential because you guys are eating
chips and i start eating chips
at the end of the episode it was like
three hours in and i was like damn i got
some chips and i was stuffed that was oh
betty hannah
uh what dan started i'm the chip master
that's my name all right guys
guys let's get on the rails explain the
meme or i don't know if it's a meme but
that dance snack
he's always eating chips i didn't get it
and he's like that's his meme i was like
oh okay
yeah that was our first episode where's
our chips can we eat chips on here why
don't we get to eat why do you need to
do that
i don't i always yell at dan because
every time you had chips you were eating
chips you were a chips on friday
i want chips they're my favorite thing
to eat that's why i get fat
we're actually at uh uh break time we
gotta go all right when we come
oh my god when we come back we're
getting back on the rails
and we're actually gonna focus on
something actually know what we're gonna
do
we're going to talk about a few other
things but we have a meme game
where i'm going to present you a meme
yeah you're going to have to explain
what it is and then create one so this
is like a meme music i know memes now
i'm very good i mean we'll we'll find
out we'll find out all right uh
stay tuned
shout out honey honey honey is a great
sponsor friend of the show some might
say
love yes we all shop online so why not
earn money and it's completely free to
download which is two clicks you can
earn money from any store like all the
stores you shop i was like 30 000 stores
or something like that
30 000 stores that range from tech
gaming products fashion and even food
delivery
honey is a free shopping tool that
scours the internet for promo codes and
implies the best one
at checkout automatically when you click
apply coupons that's easy
oh you're shopping like oh like oh
you're buying a pair of levi jeans or
whatever
boop you're ready to check out and then
honey pops up they're like oh [ __ ] we
found a cooper you don't have to search
you don't have to cut for coupons it
does it for you you get all the hard
work and then it's like 30
off 50 off yeah and then it's like boom
so
get money for shopping online what you
would do anyways
people say that magic and technology
are indistinguishable at a certain point
honey disagrees
oh i was gonna say honey is like magic
okay
honey is like magic yeah exactly i was
going somewhere
imagine you're shopping at one of your
favorite sites you check out
the honey button drops down and all you
have to do is click
apply coupon and in a few seconds watch
the magic
that is honey do its work
it'll find a working coupon and you will
just have to watch those prices drop
that's all you gotta do just watch it
drop
so if you want to save a bunch of money
and you want to support our show
go to uh
[Music]
go go to joinhoney.com fredemies
joinhoney.com friendlies i love honey i
have it on all my
all of my browsers it's freaking off it
has over 17 million members
saved over two billion dollars in
savings that's two billion dollars you
say billion with a b
billion with a b if you don't already
have honey you can be straight up
missing out on free saving
it's literally free and takes seconds to
install and by getting it you're doing
yourself a solid and supporting this
podcast by going to joinhoney.com
frenemies we say me and either save
money all the time with honey like
usually buying clothes and [ __ ] and it's
like it's like literally saving
hundreds of dollars that you were not
gonna yeah i do all my online shopping
and i have honey obviously and
even before i was like sponsored by them
i had honey and i do [ __ ]
fool and loser you're not a loser but
you know
maybe a fool some might say okay we can
debate the loser
that's join honey.com frenemies
joinhoney.com
in front of me should we sing it we have
our harmony
i'm about to tell you something amazing
amazing
we are partnered with omaze to stick it
to david dobrik
they didn't say anything about it they i
think they're fine with me saying that
okay
because we're giving away a tesla i mean
david hasn't owned tesla though
right yeah but i don't know if omaze is
like hey we're brought to you by
sticking it to david dobrik
right but they don't care about it no
we're not we're just we're just trying
to help people out no i
i sought this out specifically to stick
it to david because we're giving away a
tesla hi
on the pink side is doing it to give
someone out there a chance to uh
get a tesla so here's the deal the
winner
of this is getting a tesla model s and
20k
taxes and shipping are included oh [ __ ]
and even better every donation benefits
two great causes all you have to do is
go to omaze.com
frenemies pronounced omaze.com
frenemies for your chance to win okay
here's how it works go to omaze.com
frenemies and then you enter now you'd
make a donation
to uh this great charity which
sounds amazing give powers on a mission
to help
uh 2.2 billion people around the world
do not have access to safe
managed drinking water and these guys
are
working with solar and provide clean
water
food security and light to regions
around the world that need it
i'm all about that bro that's awesome
it purifies water sourced sustainably
from the ocean providing a long-term
renewable powered drinking water
solution for maybe many living in
brutally dry conditions so you go to
omaze.com
go to that so you can donate and you'll
also get entered to win
so if you go here and donate 10 bucks
you will be entered to win
this beauty and then winners announced
july 14th does let's go baby let's go
i kind of want to enter and then just be
like look suckers that'd be so sketchy
if i won
i don't think you can enter i'd be like
[ __ ]
i don't think anyone that knows this
connector i think that's like illegal
you're probably right good call wow
trish the lawyer
so anyway um you know listen a model
uh is that a s that's a model s in 20
grand and you're gonna be
helping support a great cause power is a
good one
so for your chance to win a custom tesla
model s plus 20 000 go to omaze.com
frenemies and enter now the best part
every donation supports the work of give
power oh and there's another one
501 501
c3 501 c3 whoever they are
um new star wars character okay so hurry
and go to
omaze.com slash fredemies go there
donate and good luck
dan said three and you came in on
two why did i have a crystal leah flash
right there you had such a crystalline
moment what did i do
in the right are you accusing me of like
sexual
impropriety no no but when you're like
uh you know yeah yeah yeah yeah
oh it's so much better without him did
you see tigo tio tigo was that her
i didn't watch the movie but there was
this big movie on netflix called the
army of the dead
which by the way there's too many of the
dead i'm like have i seen this have i
not seen this this is zack snyder
there was so many army of the dead what
of the dead the down of the dead the
night of the dead the army of the dead
the [ __ ] uh minecraft of the dead the
hamburger of the dead
it's like i got it i get it
there's too many zombie films and now
crystal is like the podcast of the dead
not to tap dance on his grave that's not
very 2021 trisha of you
i think there's certain people who
deserve cancellations
like james charles like things with
minors cancelled brag i'm trying i'm
having a hard time matching your energy
but hey because when you got all amped
up
no but no no no but this was a zack
snyder film yeah no it was a big deal
damn
and you know they spent three million
dollars reshooting his scenes with pig
in the in the green screen that was
definitely a slap to chris because it's
like a
little lesbian to replace it i love her
i was down
she looked dope she was like tom cruise
in the movie no but like because he's
like this
tall right like male 1 popular and then
they're like [ __ ] you we're going to
like you
masculinity we got tig over here the
movie looks better and funnier
the movie doesn't even see it i said it
looks dumb did you watch it no no i
always talking to you
exactly i said i watched 10 minutes of
schindler's list and now i understand
the holocaust much more than 10 minutes
of this one though this was better than
that
but zack snyder was the thing and he
said he was it was just to be clear
army of the dead is better than
schindler's for sure okay and zack
snyder said it was
a no-brainer to replace crystalia he
said that was not ev that was an obvious
choice that would replace him after the
after his scandal so there are certain
things like harvey weinstein forever
cancellation chrisley forever
cancellation there are certain people
you know
underage stop stop messing with underage
people that's it you know like don't
feed them alcohol don't force them into
having sex don't be
verbally abused don't you know they're
simple rules yeah sexting no armpits for
people under 18.
james charles shout out here james here
here's a grown man's armpit what dan you
don't like what you see i'm just gonna
have to blur that
too sexy good for you james there was a
photo of bryce hall when he was like 16
with james charles and james charles
commented on that and daddy when he was
16. i was like real sick
[ __ ] that's what i'm saying okay i want
to talk about positivity we're positive
no
um no but i'm just i'm trying to raise
my energy levels
okay so here let me let's just go
through uh so
trisha you were in a okay can you tell
me the educational value of this
this is your tick tock in a classroom i
love it i haven't seen this
i think but yeah but like what's the
educational value here can somebody
explain
that i'm just killing it in the world
why are you in a classroom doing
king tut i i mean this was an iconic
talk i think
like here is the most egregious example
of cultural appropriation we've ever
seen
no i am not appropriating that culture i
bought their likes here they're like
here is how to go
no i have a little bit of egyptian in me
actually really how much yeah i think
like
like maybe two percent don't you have
like two percent of everything when you
go far enough back
it might be more than two percent maybe
it was like i remember seeing egyptian
on that i don't know i don't want to
quote anything but i do i did have a
little egyptian of me so
romney malek and me could be related i
just want to know why
are they doing this to these kids what
are these kids is this
is this detention this is after school
detention
like it or not you know i've been around
for a minute you know i've been like the
beginning oh why are you in school
i'm being institutionalized they're like
this is how you do tick-tock
institutionalized
all right isn't that when you get
arrested and you spend your life in
prison
i don't know um i i was no
institutionalized it's not a word like
where you like
it is a word okay thank you okay so
trish is in the classroom
101. the new uh it's a new uh
it's a pre-recreate class moses was like
i want to look at tic-tacs and bed i'm
like i want to see your dick doc in my
bed
you said that to him nice
let's see that dick talk let's see that
dick talk
dick talk isn't that funny pretty funny
trisha
oh ew i hate this okay then another
little quick update kevin spacey got a
roll again
but wait he's playing a pedo hunting
detective i see you kevin i know who you
are
we like to have it started by saying we
liked kevin's well before all this like
american beauty he was like such a good
actor
like of course everyone loved him but
this is a perfect example jerry seinfeld
of how you can't differentiate art
between the
artists what did kevin do he was like he
was like essaying a young
actor or something r worded uh the r
word anthony rap from rent
oh my goodness and a lot of ben platt
okay
huh i don't know i was like does it have
a correlation
i don't think it has a correlation you
said something about broadway i thought
it been planned
anthony rapp um yeah i guess i think he
r-worded
anthony rapp oh boy when he was a young
boy and so he's and no one believed him
that anthony
that you know so he kind of got a little
bit blacklisted from um like so how does
kevin get a role
as a pedo hunting detective is this
because it's the only role available to
him
they're like wouldn't it be funny
they're like wait wouldn't it be funny
kevin spacey
if you played a detective hunting pedos
imagine that ah
imagine it i feel like this has like
bill gates written all over it but like
i feel like woody allen could get a role
if he played
a child molester um he's like i have a
movie for you it's perfect a dude who r
words his own daughter
go oh i like the director hands you know
i don't think it's
perfect for you woody i think i think
this is like propaganda right i think
someone is trying to like make it like
hey look like this could happen being
falsely accused trying to make it seem
like he was
cute you know what he means so he's
hunting a pedo hunter who was falsely
accused i was like okay kevin
oh no i see you how is he not permanent
but you know what i mean this should be
a permanent cancellation
you know like beyond frenemies that
should be like cnn
this dude gave him a role and now we're
talking about it i guess if you don't
care about anything i
i care about it i care about it too do
you think more people watch this than
cnn
then cnn yeah maybe maybe cnn doesn't
get that many views right then they get
like a million
on like their top rated show so yeah we
crushed cnn this is
[ __ ] cnn for news
i mean why do you ask can we put a
disclaimer on that like don't come to us
for a news like i just haven't
oh no you know what i mean i know
exactly what i'm talking about you do
oh yeah h3 don't come to fredericksburg
come to frenemies for news
and whatever else you're looking for can
i also make a clarification and
disclaimer for the rest of my life like
anything i say about politics i'm
ignorant don't listen to me the rest of
your life yeah i'm so stupid like people
cancel me they're trying
i was getting cancelled over the weekend
and i didn't even know what i was
talking about so just i apologize for
anything i don't
talked about israel palestine i don't
know what i'm talking about i think i
know what i'm talking about just but you
know what people wanted me to speak up
and then i spoke up and i feel like
she's a dumbass no no no not that way
yeah and i was like i don't know what
i'm doing oh you misunderstood that so
far
they go trisha speak up about israel
palestine so trisha goes to instagram
and goes and then defends israel because
i see i follow a lot of people and i was
just like
they're like no no no no no not that way
i just don't want any hate but it's
never like okay always matter and i just
thought i was doing a good thing saying
like every nobody should get hate to
support people but
i don't know what's happening well yeah
i think i saw what you posted
it was a bad thing no i think i think it
was not the right time
okay but i get your point there's a lot
of anti-semitism right now and it's good
to be aware of it and speak out okay
well that's all i was saying i don't
think that's what they meant it's
because palestine's being like bomb
but i said what's happening in
palestine's horrific and i don't even
grasp i can't even grasp it so
i'm sorry i really just don't know
anything and maybe don't don't encourage
me to speak up you know maybe other
influencers should speak up i don't
think i should don't
yeah tristan should not be sharing her
political issues i hear what is wrong
with you guys why are you asking
christian to share thoughts with
political issues you know
you do though so many people were like
talk about this and i was like i don't
know what's happening and even when i
tried to educate that and like listen
you just you know i don't know what's
happening so i was
i just want to be one of the female
wiggles what's a wiggle a wiggle
i want to be her so bad the wiggles
fruit salad
yummy yummy another broadway thing you
should know the wiggles it's a little
boy it's for a little yeah
it's like a little yeah bring up the
wiggles what's a wiggle yellow trippy
balls bro
talking about wiggles oh she's yeah can
we dress up as the wiggles well let me
unders see what they
are first you'll love them just wiggle
them just wiggle that's it wiggles the
wiggles
yeah i'm surprised theodore doesn't want
it it's like a little kid's thing
big red car we'll travel near and we'll
travel far
[ __ ] are these [ __ ] no they put a
female one in there
okay aren't they australian yeah oh you
know what's up
you wanna dress as them no we'll perform
for theodore
that'd be fun he would like he doesn't
even know who they are doesn't know the
wiggles are
do you want to pick up for real we
talked about that can i be the boy scout
i'll be the puppy boy scout and he can
be the old man
oh of up yeah that sounds like the
premise of something i don't want to be
involved in
the boy scout and the old man i'm sorry
trisha i'm not
i'm not getting involved is it
problematic the way you describe it
also the green hat does not go today
with your ally but okay
yeah if you want to look ill they put
green on them how do i look you said i
look good thank you well a little sickly
what the heck
okay okay let's take the hat off james
charles i just my hair is getting a
little unruly oh can i tell you what i
want to do
i want to start exercising every morning
right now i'm doing two sessions a week
with my trainer one hour i want to start
doing it every morning
and then here's something else i want to
do start tapering off antidepressants
wow that's i'm scared though why why
just because you think
well i've been on them for a while now
and i think maybe
maybe it's time i'm supportive of that i
mean i'm supporting people on it but
like i got off mine and i
like i felt better but that was just me
personally no i i think
the antidepressants helped me in a lot
and like they helped me so much in a lot
of ways yeah yeah
but i but i just think maybe i don't
know that i'm trying i want to be on it
my whole life
i don't think they are supposed to be
for your whole i mean they can be but i
think also like
some people just need it temporarily for
whatever but maybe you're getting like
serotonin from working out like are you
feeling better about yourself you know
yeah i think the
exercising helps a lot with like
self-confidence and self-worth
that's and if i can lose the weight
actually and i know being off
antidepressants will help lose the
weight yeah
but if i can actually lose the weight i
feel like my self-confidence in my but
like
you know i'm afraid of going back to
being so irritable which
was my problem before i started
anti-depressants did you
talk to your doctor what did he say is
he like weaning you off like a little
little dosage
i'm going to talk to my psychiatrist
about it i stopped and i don't remember
this i'm not psychologists don't listen
to me but i stopped cold turkey but i
don't know that's the thing you should
do well i don't know where you want it
for losses i've been on for like two
hours no i wasn't i was only six months
oh yeah yeah okay
i was on for like six months and i like
one yeah you're not supposed to do that
no but you felt better immediately you
just went right off it
that's yeah medical advice by the way
really bad medical advice
for me personally i was very like i
literally had suicidal thoughts all the
time on it was very weird like when i
was driving the car thinking let me just
go oh you should you should discontinue
immediately if that's the case
but with the doctor's supervision no my
doctor was trying to like wean me off
and i was like you know let me just yeah
i know better every day i was like let
me dumb a psychiatrist how much school
have you had
12 years no no again my experience only
but like every time i'd get in the car i
would think of what i could crash into i
was like i want to crash in that person
i'm going to crash into that tree and
then as soon as the medication but as
soon as i was off of it i was like not
thinking those things anymore so i don't
know i
you know look the the antidepressant has
side effects of course you know they
affect you in different ways i think i
might have been misdiagnosed maybe it
wasn't like depression i think it might
have been something you know what i mean
like i just think maybe it was a mistake
no i don't know there was something
crossing
because i was on medication like i'm
supposed to did you try that
i don't really know because i should
maybe shouldn't hang on it yet because
it's also kind of like an experimental
not experimental but it's like in the
beginning phases sort of thing
the new medicine or it's approved okay
so wait let me ask you yeah yeah so you
st so how long have you been taking the
new medicine it's like two
three weeks that's a good amount of time
to start getting therapeutic value
i don't know if it's like changing me or
if i'm like what's that placebo effect
where you're just like i think i'm
changing because i'm on this medication
or do you think it's a real drug it may
be real well you are taking a real
medicine so it's not placebo
it could be because sometimes they say
it takes what like two months or so yeah
yeah so i'm like i think i'm getting
better you know
well that's great i mean if you feel
better at all then then that's
great right yeah
well i don't really hear like talking in
my head as much anymore that's a huge
win
mm-hmm right but is that like placebo
again where i'm just like i'm taking a
pill no more voices and the voices are
stopping well
well you are taking a real medicine so
you know probably not i told them to
stop
one day i was just like stop and they
stopped
i wish i could do that to my depression
no no i know i sound crazy
i'm diagnosed crazy i'm legitimately
like i wish i could just be like stop
maybe try it be firm with yourself
be firm with your depression be like you
know what stop right now we're done with
this today i think the way to beat my
depression is just like
hard work self-care taking care of
myself to making the right choices i
think that's
that'll make the big decision maybe
frenemies twice a week oh
[ __ ] i think that's going to make me put
me on [ __ ] the cliff
no i'm pumped i'm pumped well what we
are doing
is we're gonna be doing vlogs every
other week we're back tomorrow we're
filming one tomorrow no spoilers but i
think we'll be out on thursday
oh you don't want to spoil you want to
spoil it we can should we tell
no don't spoil okay spoil don't spoil
it's fun
oh no spoiled it's something in public
don't interfere with us don't fear that
because we're like we're like cavemen
you know when the aliens come they say
don't interfere with the life yeah
like pavements don't interfere i get
yeah
okay speaking of pedals anyway i'm
really excited to try that i think i'm
just gonna go for it you seem happier
and honestly like i'm gonna try working
out every day too
not every day but at least like a couple
times because i was feeling so good when
i was working out too and you inspire
me and even i don't lose weight like at
least feeling good like i feel like i'm
working my body and i'm not gonna die
because
yeah cause like my pro i get these
things a lot
is like at night especially there's just
like so much self-clothing about like
you [ __ ] pig you're so fat you're not
doing anything about it you're so weak
that's a nighttime thing that happens a
lot people and i meet you and now you
get like dark and depressed and then i
go tomorrow i'm gonna conquer the day
and then it's like the same thing
me every day and at night it's like that
i'm such a [ __ ] douche i'm so weak i
can't do any you know
yeah my eating i'm like that to my
eating is like i'm like i'm not going to
eat anything tomorrow which is so bad
it's like a
disorder but and then i eat and i'm like
oh you have no self control you piece of
[ __ ]
yeah you gotta eat though eat your meals
eat you know eat when you're hungry into
eating that's why food food addiction is
such a [ __ ] it's because
you can quit heroin cold turkey but you
can't quit eating
i'd rather eat you gotta [ __ ] eat to
live for sure
as far as i know some people say you
just have to breathe air
water you've seen that [ __ ] no who said
that some weird gurus are like i just
breathed bruh
really yeah i want to get on that they
they almost died of starvation how do
you breathe
okay they found out they were sneaking
food
really yeah there's a whole
investigation into them oh my god
never sneaking food i heard that about
gandhi he used to sneak food too
gandhi probably hungry as [ __ ] he used
to sneak food they're like he didn't go
as fast he was like sneaking food i was
like oh [ __ ]
he's skinny legend though rest in peace
yeah for sure rest in peace to
he was like cheating too he was like
with multiple women and stuff he's
always having like sex with people
dude it's amazing how dudes just like
every powerful guy is just [ __ ]
everybody
what is that why do you think that is
it's just like what
i think it's part of the personality of
these like super driven people
yeah that they just like have this urge
to
i brought i don't really know i think
it's like an insecure thing i think it's
like they were
getting out of the power like they get
like power horny you know what i mean
like oh i got all this power i can [ __ ]
anybody now
just like all the yeah yeah i don't know
i'm not sure i've been with a lot of
like sex addicts and stuff like that and
i don't know what
there's something wrong with them no no
peace and love but you know sex
addiction i've known a few sex addicts
that's like one of the most destructive
addictions there is because you really
can't it's like it's like anything
like you can't help yourself all your
relationships it's super destructive to
everyone you sleep with
a lot of them people that you sleep with
it's just it's super fun oh yeah it's
really bad but like get help
i had a really close friend in israel
who was a sex addict and it like
destroyed his family
and they were like so yeah but they were
like such they were like such a good
couple and a beautiful child and it was
just like [ __ ]
yeah i think i think for cause i think i
was sex at one point i think it's like
an insecure thing like i really do think
i was a sex editor one more right have
sex like six times a day with like
different people
like it was crazy like i was on tinder
and i really like for me i don't know
maybe i wasn't a sex addict but i do i
did feel like i was and i was just like
to me it was like this really like it
was a validation you felt like love for
like an hour like someone loved you for
like an hour i don't know that's what
but i don't know maybe it's different
for me but no i know what you mean i
mean um yeah
you want to feel sexy and like wanted
and then like that's how i thought was
like going about it so i was like that
for like a really long time it was like
crazy
that makes sense anyways i don't know
but hey hey like it's cool
you seem pretty monogamous now though
like you are like not wanting to do like
scenes with other people well i mean
always in a relationship i was but
yeah i was always when i was but the
thing is i used to be like addicted to
sex and relationship i'd want like
six times a day because i thought that
was the only way to get attention from
my partner
like it was so now like being in a like
a normal relationship i was like oh like
he'll give me attention even if i'm not
having sex with him that's interesting
yeah well i mean that makes sense
because i mean it's like you've had
these relationships these
these unconventional relationships with
sex your whole life yeah and that should
[ __ ] you up
for sure alfred and you don't think it
does that's why it's so destructive when
these [ __ ] up adults
[ __ ] with kids and it's so unforgiving i
get so mad even older men with like
young girls like 18 years like i don't
there was like
anyways i'm not gonna get into it but
like i did see an influencer who was 18
and now she's like 23 and she goes i'm
like in deep therapy for like talking
about
yeah whatever i don't want to be that
person that harps on it but but
it is destructive when like your own 40
year old men are with like trying to get
with 18 year olds who don't want it who
think oh maybe i need it for power or
clout or whatever you know it's like
it's [ __ ] up
women think that it's like normal to use
sex as like a tool
and that [ __ ] everybody up i get really
pissed about because i didn't think it
[ __ ] me up until i realized it did it
now when i see that [ __ ]
i'm like oh i'm like one guy like
whatever she's like 18 but it's like no
they're still not fully developed no
18 is a really but then under 18 it's
even more [ __ ] up so when i read that
disposition with christianity that's why
i come from him so hard like no one
talks about where he come from whenever
the disposition of that 17 year old
and the abuse and like the psychological
abuse the like this meanness
yeah she was 17. i mean
that's good dan that's a good impression
right she was 17.
i mean come on jim carrey a little bit
though oh that was good though that was
good
uh not cool what am i supposed to do
not [ __ ] her
no but he's you know whatever i
apologize to people i came hard for if
they're looked i shouldn't make my
people's looks last week people were
i was upset i get triggered i get
triggered i make fun feels like i'm not
gonna do anymore it's not cool it's not
fine i had a horrible week last week
because i was talking in front of
people's looks
at a horrible week last week i'm sorry
it all comes back
yeah i'm only holding people accountable
who do the who do bad things to minors
and speaking of people who did bad
things to minors
james charles is back on social media
when did he come back he posted for his
birthday now yesterday was it i believe
and um you will not believe the amount
of support he's getting
his smile though which is like a lot
it's a lot happening in this photo with
the cupcake and the
and the dog look at it like pick it
apart well we can because he he's he's
sexting boys and getting away with it
underage so
what's this dude what's this key to
probably the dungeon where he keeps all
the 17 year old armpit hair
yep correct dancer
oh yeah james is his bad knee he just is
you know
so this post got just apologized to
dixie emilio i'm really sorry people
keep bringing up the dicks now you're
right i i should have made fun of her
for the snail thing
i appreciate it i was just being you
know i saw everyone doing it i was like
okay whatever and your music's you good
you're like 19 you're like killing it i
know she doesn't care cause she's like
killing it but you're killing it
i love your show i'd love to be on dixie
early late show i like that about the
the
the charlotte dixie i didn't i'm sorry
they're not really problematic they
don't like they like were mean
that you got exchanges but like as far
as people on the internet go like
they're nice
they weren't even the meanest like james
was mean like he started jumping in
the dixie carly thing psycho and i was
like okay but yeah i
apologize i really do like her show she
has a really late show that has a
by the way her says bomb why can't we
get a set like hers
they got like crazy familiar god where i
we need to get that anyway they got the
meliobox
i hope they cut james charles out
because i like the demilios i like your
music
well you know um uh bella porch cut him
out of here
build a [ __ ] but there was smoker on
his face did you see that well there was
other things she cut him out of
and then they couldn't confirm do you
want to say that yeah it's confirmed
people are talking about all over the
internet she didn't say anything though
well whatever she cut him out that's
good yeah she's she's like you know
bye but i love how they put smoke over
his face in fact can you can you
find that i want to find the smoke scene
can you put more smoke over they're like
oh it's so smoky i can't see that
and then the smoke follows him it's like
oh
there's so much smoke they probably had
to pay an extra 10 000 for that effect
to smoke him out so yeah
that's very good for you did you ever
talk about the connection to that or no
you guys don't talk about it
we don't have to what connection
nevermind to the [ __ ] oh that ela was
invited
i can talk she would have been cool in
that video i don't know whatever
it was just a short notice i mean yeah
bella invited eli to be one of the
builders no i know i know i was like
because they're like friends with her
and stuff that i didn't know
that i just thought it was cool that she
got asked i was like an iconic
yeah it would have been really cool now
that i've seen the video and no but at
the time she's like it was like a last
minute no she's like we need like 12
hours and neil was like
you know he looks busy as [ __ ] yeah no i
know but it was i like that video i like
it it's good
i like it too i'm glad that they blurred
out they didn't put them in the credits
either
well he wasn't in it you got smoked
[ __ ] i thought mia cleaves behind the
scenes they had to wear these itty bitty
body suits oh she would have killed
she would look good she would have been
like oh my god oh showing so much
yeah because she's not really really
yeah but of course she would look good
yeah yeah
so anyway james's post got 2 million
likes so
she should be in a queen tarantino movie
gila okay oh can we also clarify the
it's moses says hila so i've been saying
hila but she said on your h3 that it
could be either way
yeah okay people will be like trish is
disrespecting me like he literally says
hila all the time
i like ela too i like both but i okay
sorry i just want to clear for that
because
in israel people call her gila yeah or
they say
yeah that's what i'm gonna say i like it
okay
did you say happy birthday i thought it
said ethan okay so he got two million
likes so like he's fully like
he's fully sw embraced you know people
don't give a [ __ ] but here's the crazy
part so there's tons of verified
accounts wishing him happy birthday
saying we miss you and [ __ ]
now let's just remind you that james was
sexting like 17 fans like 12 of which
were under age going as young as 14.
yeah gross and the fact that there's the
top comments the underage and the fans
that's
so much manipulation and power play oh
yeah the dm's are like
super gross dude okay so who do you know
any of these people
hung van gogh who's that i don't know no
idea they look fake like that one's like
lindsay lohan's picture or something
do you know who any of these people are
okay hope you're okay we miss you he's
like okay
no no i guess you like supporting
[ __ ] like predators
seriously this is like one gabrielle do
you know any of these people no but i
love roxanne you have the audacity to
post yeah that one is a lot like shout
out to roxanne lmao
wait i thought there was more there
weren't really many check marks
um and interestingly also jason nash
has the same birthday as james charles i
don't know if you wanted to wash him a
happy birthday happy birthday jason i am
really sorry for making fun of your
looks i still think you're a piece of
[ __ ] but i shouldn't have come for your
face
right i believe you said he looked like
a dead [ __ ]
i take that back that was mean you said
he looked like he was dead in the eyes
um that might be a soul-searching thing
he did look dead behind the eyes that
was not about his look so
you stand by the the dead in the soul we
take back the horse
i think like the horse the dead horse
you don't look like a dead horse i
was triggered by your by you and i
shouldn't have watched it but happy
birthday
because honestly you deserve a happy
birthday
you mean that yeah i feel bad for him
right now i think things are tough so
happy birthday
okay all right so we get a merciful
happy birthday to jason
i should have said his face looks like
dog poop or whatever i said you said
you said a dead horn a dead [ __ ] i'm
sorry that was bad i felt bad it was a
little mean
i was triggered you took i was going
back in time
to eat all the chicken nuggets he's like
you ate ten chicken nuggets that's all i
was thinking of in that moment i was
thinking like
i've seen a lot of the clips of him food
shaming you yeah i had an eating
disorder after that
i was like jason why are you dating
someone who like
loves to eat it's like pray right right
and then like shame her
i saw him make some really nasty
comments to you about like you would
look good if you lost 10 pounds yeah
yeah yeah you look good in a size you'd
always say that he's like oh i think
you're gonna just try and get hot after
we break up and lose some weight i'm
like
okay i feel like i'm pretty high gained
it
gained it but uh whatever man i wish a
while
they're coming back in june david and
jason are coming back with views in june
they'll be fine
everybody's fine nobody cares about
anything you know i might think and let
me just say that's not
well over because i'm on a high right
now i'm on a manic high so i'm going to
try and keep it there but just real
quick i want to say
like yes i have to have my past and i'm
like i i don't try and hang on people's
past but if you can't even like
acknowledge like david at least
acknowledged twice that he did something
wrong right but like jason can't even
acknowledge
the situations at hand that were talked
about you know with all these things
with like you know
tana's in therapy you know seth with his
thing like all this [ __ ] you can't even
like acknowledge it
yeah just accountability goes a long way
and that's what i was trying to say it's
like i try and hold people accountable
because everyone should be held at the
same standard of being accountable for
their actions
i wonder if jason is not speaking on it
publicly because there's like lawyers
involved maybe
i don't know that i'm just speculating
because what he jason's been accused of
an actual like
essay and so maybe for him admitting
like oh
that was bad or something is like his
lawyers like don't do that
i guess if there's a lawsuit happening
but if he did something bad admit it i
don't know
at least have redemption in your soul
that's why i was saying the soul behind
his eyes is then
right but yeah i don't know i just
trisha may forgive you but god doesn't
i can't make that i cannot do it
we just sealed that i can't say what
god's gonna do
but did you see that one guy who
murdered a an orthopedic like someone
like james charles he like murdered the
guy
and he's like i don't have a right to
judge him but i like only god does but i
gave him like
a fast pass to that judgment did you see
that no what was that someone recently i
don't know
i mean you know that's good he didn't
judge him i remember the story of a dad
who killed the dude who r-worded his
daughter and the judge
didn't even sentence him to jail they
just gave him like probation
whoa was that texas i don't know florida
probably yeah
i don't know okay let's move it on texas
and florida ma'am
they do [ __ ] different there boy like
for example
here's a speaking of florida i wanted to
show you this oh there's weird high
school
there's this high school in florida and
um thank you very much
i'm a professional that was good
and they in the yearbook images they the
parents and students noticed oh it's
scary that the
they had edited out cleavage on the
girls
from the 80s like okay look at this no
no this just happened
so like by the way i don't know if you
could even call this cleavage but this
is what she showed
and then this is what they photoshopped
and they're like
what the [ __ ] the family showed up and
they're like what is going on here so
they go
here that much whatever and then here's
a girl like
oh oh well a little cleaner photoshop
than this one of these
that's now cleavage though like i'm
sorry when did we turn into these
puritanical [ __ ] losers they can't
even see a little bit of a
well is it is it a puritanical school is
it a christian school like what kind of
school
i think it's a public school based on
how they're dressing that's crazy public
schools by i wasn't like that though
they like they were they told me i
couldn't show my arms
i was like fat and so i was like the
only person who couldn't show my arms
and had like a little they thought
oh you're so lucky no it wasn't even
that so i have like a little bit of
no i have a fat in between my boob and
my armpit is that cycle i just made that
up
they told me it was side move i'm like
that's just fat in my arms
excuse me they've never let me wear
sleeveless like i always had to have
sleeves down here when everyone else
yeah schools are wild man
they wouldn't let us in my high school
they wouldn't let us wear hats because
they thought it was part of gang
association i was like
i was like everybody wears [ __ ] well
you are ventura county
you know there was no gang members at my
high school dude we should go visit your
high school should we go over to your
high school and visit it and see what
it's like and like take a year and a day
in the life of ethan as a high schooler
no
okay why would i want to do that you
weren't in high school
high school was fine but i'm not like
going to run back and be like remember
me you go up to all your teachers
remember me
like the same teachers who have been
like living miserably teaching these
[ __ ] pieces of [ __ ] and getting paid
nothing
and then they gotta deal with all these
school kids coming back be like you
remember me
they're like no i don't remember you i
teach a billion people maybe we could do
our field day there like our track and
field competition at your high school
that'd be fun are we gonna do that let
me think about it remember i suggested
we do some hurdles
i used to be hurdles all right i can
jump a hurdle
i can do it i'm trying to jump some
hurdles and what's the other one the
marathon where you like relay with the
baton race i can do that how about the
uh
pole vault i never did that is that a
thing uh yeah
in high school really damn anyway
um like i'm sorry freaks like
and then this one like what they're just
they're conservative
maybe i don't know you know i don't know
i don't see anything like terrible with
it so they wanted to cover up some
cleavage
you know bro they're not they're like
dressed so conservatively they're
ruining their photos
but maybe especially this poor girl like
i'm sorry what
explain that one to your kids no it's
whole [ __ ] but it's like you know
whatever
well they didn't tell them they didn't
ask permission and they're like they did
this to like
the story is they did it to like um
like 50 different people 150 different
people let me see
we got the story here 80 different
photos were edited
but here's a little controversy for you
there's plenty of boys
and speedos that were not edited so
where's the oh
like what do we think of this i mean
look at this i mean
fine i'm not yeah i'm just sick oh right
the bulge
well i don't know the guys are like
practically naked by comparison why are
these girls getting
um yeah shame that's all that's been the
world like guys you just show their
nipples why can't i show my nipples like
what the hell like so crazy
right that's [ __ ] it is [ __ ] i
mean it's [ __ ] supposed but
i've noticed there's a there's a trend
girls have stopped wearing bras have you
noticed that i never wear a bra
brawl as always why why should we be
constricted restricted
i didn't even know that a wire i didn't
even know that bras were so
uncomfortable
no more wire bras no more wire hangers
bras are awful right yeah they're so
it's like the mask on your face like you
just want to take it off and just think
of a holding it's a
it's a boulder shoulder strap kayla does
she takes off her bra
i won't even wear i just don't wear one
just if you don't even wear one go
braless it's 20 21.
but i do feel like girls are not wearing
bras anymore just something
yeah because like why why why why why
why why why hey god bless dude why wear
a bra tell me why you wear a bra
i don't know why exactly well okay so i
correct me if i'm wrong this is this is
like ethan
explains why you wear a bra yeah okay
well so first of all they think it's
like
helps them not drooping oh but yeah they
said that's not true
i feel like i've read that that's not
the truth that broads don't
prevent drooping there's probably truth
to that because like think about your
running and
the day-to-day yes they probably do fall
like i feel might have fallen and stuff
like that so it probably does support it
and some would argue you know back pain
like you know especially mine like if
i'm running i want it
running or walking you need support
especially if you got like bigger
bigger ones love this know that they can
get like really and i know because i've
got like
bees now going like a's and i feel that
when i run i'm like oh
[ __ ] you feel them well like if we're
going to fasten my [ __ ] down if we're in
target i'm like picking up lacroix or
something i'll put a bra on because you
know if you're bending over yeah it
hurts like it hurts i guess but i don't
like oh you put them on by lacroix
yeah because that means i'm gonna bend
down to get them and bring them up you
know
and i guess the other ring reason is to
keep like your nipples from going crazy
oh well that's a [ __ ] one then
shirts yeah but who cares they're
nipples
i'm just get i don't i'm not i'm not
giving a value judgment i'm just saying
this is why
yeah the other two reasons okay i can
see whatever if you want to wear
broadway i think just support because
you have these big
things going on there but i want to show
these things going on here you know
there you go god bless you
there's only people that want to see him
so it's like
would you go on the joe rogan podcast if
he asked you
oh boy i would love to see you on there
because like you always said
what do you talk about i feel like he
hates me no on friday's episode it was
interesting because you're like all the
comics go on they're like kisses ask us
the ring as you said i was like oh
that's so interesting so then i wondered
if you would go on because like if i was
on there i'd [ __ ] come back
you know what i mean like if if it
called to if i was like you know what if
there's call to combat i'll come back
but i don't think you're com you're not
confrontational like that i don't think
you come back
so if he said why like the masked thing
like oh my god why would you like wear
mascara why would you have accidentally
you're stupid oh just kiss the ring
like if he's like you're young and
healthy why are you getting vaccination
you think i would just kiss the ring i
don't know i don't know what you would
do i don't know what you would do i
don't but you're not confrontational
either so what would you do
like whatever you don't think i'm
confrontational that's like the whole
show
no the whole premise of the world but
i've seen you on other podcasts where
you're very just kind of
yeah because there's no confrontation
okay
and when i'm sitting with friends
there's no confrontation we just shoot
the [ __ ] we talk
somebody's coming at me with some covet
misinformation i'm gonna [ __ ]
clap back yeah yeah big time there's
another thing i kind of like debate him
on because i have no idea about that
that's also i feel it's like if he's
trying to get into like i'm not here i
can't debate you don't want to do a
cover debate
i don't think you're pretty sure you're
pretty passionate about your covenants
and he's pretty passionate about his
covenants how they always be like
because if he wants to debate covert he
should get a scientist on not me
not a representative you know what i
mean no but i feel like he's kind of
he's also like not an expert you know
what i mean so it's like two non-experts
like just going at it about
we talked about joe rogan our last step
because he he slammed
ela yeah i saw that i was wondering if
like you would go on there
um i don't know interesting i don't
think he'll ever invite me because
i feel like he doesn't like me would you
go on like a bench of hero podcast
no he's all he's ben shapiro is always
trying to collab with me and i've always
said
oh really i feel like all those
conservative guys hate me now because
like
they thought i was one of them for a
long time really is that you were
conservative
or they thought i was just like cool
edgy independent guy and then when like
ben shapiro kept trying to get me on his
show
and trying to come on my show and i was
like nah [ __ ] that someone told me i
love
her ben shapiro i'm like i don't know
what he does you look like just like
benchmark not
look sounds like she reminds me of ben
shapiro and i was like what is he like
political i don't know how do you
what about you is vengeance i'll
screenshot that i don't even know him i
just
want to both talk really fast
he talks super fast really that's kind
of his thing okay let's move
on because we're okay and then the
adrian kicked back hook is the [ __ ] we
got we're running out of time let's do
meme
okay yeah okay but who's adrian real
quick i don't care about it i don't care
to know about it
it's kind of a funny story so adrian
kickback is some random dude who posted
on tick tock here of the video
it was a random guy just some random
dude who posted a tick tock he was like
yo come through i'm having a birthday
party at this time of this event
like a super small account not expecting
anything and then all these
tick talkers were like i'll be there
dude here's the original tick tock it
was just this
i love that adrian kickback location uh
huntington beach at the fire pits date
may 22 bring your own
e what's e c i think
in this case everything bring it up
bring it on everything i was like
ecstasy they're gonna have a wild ass
bites are two hundred dollars a piece
our wedding invites and we're inviting
like 250 people how much money is that
just for the
just for the invitation
bro that's how much we paid per head
me and ela on our wedding in israel we
paid 350 dollars per person
for the wedding oh really you're
spending almost as much just on the
invitation what's
what am i getting like a watch no yeah
you're getting a box it's a it's a
package it's a box
yeah yeah i was getting everyone's
addresses i
told dan again what's your address at
your table
wait are all the guys getting invited
well i don't know anybody else but i
guess
i can i don't know that's awkward now
just dan i like that i just know diane
because i see him every week
yeah bring down him down yeah no i'm i'm
that'll be being
thrilled to come really because you know
when you see something
in israel
people are not like i don't know why
we're like worrying about their own oh
but we are doing
and make a plan right now in israel
because you don't know that that's true
well we already paid so much but anyways
it's like we're trying to
sink into that [ __ ] so far we've put
like 18 000 in but
but maui maui for sure is happening this
year by the way we haven't told you but
it's for sure happening so wait you're
having one in l.a and one in maui yeah
i want to go to maui it's for sure i got
a box for that wait a minute can i go to
that one
yeah no honestly come we we blocked out
the it's like the hotel's bouge it's
amazing
so we gotta like let you know we should
shoot can i shoot a vlog so we can like
pay for the trip
no a frenemy's vlog or my wedding oh but
not like
oh is that not good that's no good this
is like a lot oh you already have a
[ __ ] reality show
it's not like i was like i was like whoa
maybe trisha wants privacy and then i
was like wait you're talking with a
reality show to make a video for each
wedding it's just like a lot
of weddings like already happening
there's a lot happening because it's
like bougie like it's a bougie wedding
okay i'll be there we're doing
festivities like you don't even know no
pictures
no pictures no videos i get you i get
your trip we can't if it's not like a
sit down like we planned something i
don't whatever i'll be there whatever it
is you get you get [ __ ]
if you guys get married in the pit where
saddam hussein was caught i'll be there
it's going to be really fun um you can
break theater if you want or
not whatever you want uh we'll see
probably leave them with my parents
okay because uh we have a little kids we
have someone just because logistically
when you bring a kid
it changes everything yeah yeah it's all
about him it's no longer about trisha
and moses being married it's more well
there's other kids coming so
that's fine i don't expect it to all be
about me
i want it to be all about you ken moses
by the way who's my brother-in-law too
yeah yeah all about me
you're not the only person getting
married i feel like it sometimes but
he's great he is so supportive of it
yeah cause daddy osmond you know we want
we're getting close to having him at our
wedding and i was just like
are you [ __ ] the deal with donald
trump yeah and i was like well maybe
hopefully he's not well we're in there
but
[ __ ] donnie just take the offer but
then i was like i asked him like do you
think he let me sing with him like i
want to do a duet
[ __ ] no why wouldn't he light you you
already paid why did you care
he do us with the sisters okay i'll pay
the full price but can i do it with you
he's like
excuse me [ __ ] [ __ ] you i don't let
anyone sing with me
me and moses are sitting at the wedding
we're singing a song together too i
can't wait i'm gonna get trashed
i don't get trashed anymore like i have
not gotten drunk in like
a decade i'm going to trash your wedding
yeah
it's not going to be cute oh you're like
family though you guys oh my god are you
okay yeah i'm okay
yeah you're gonna have like family
people there's so many places to see
you're like family oh yeah you have to
just family okay there's a lot happening
okay
cool and your mom's gonna be there
that's gonna be super fun it's a family
affair
okay can't wait i'll bring my own
ecstasy as well
well the invitation did not cost 200
that's why i made me think of my
invitation
i can't wait to see this invite bro it's
dope it better be amazing it's
it's insane there's so many things in
the box it plays music and there's like
sand
yeah it's really cool you guys still get
as far as you can go for wedding invites
i feel like yeah ours is going to be the
boogies that you can get i'm like i
don't care
what you want you invited how many
people 230.
so 200 times 230. so you guys are
spending just on the invites alone
50 000. yeah
but maybe that's why people need to go
buy subway merch so i can
oh yeah don't worry that's sad by march
time you got close to covering that [ __ ]
i don't even think i'm gonna profit that
video cost me like a hundred thousand i
think i'll laugh
[Laughter]
what the [ __ ] i'm just living the dream
i'm doing my own this [ __ ] doesn't care
about making money
just don't i don't i honestly have no
idea well you would think if you're
selling merch you would be at least do
crunching some numbers be like okay i'm
going to make a little bit of
i don't want to make any i think you're
going to lose money yeah that's probably
100
000. but it was fun to make the video
that's all that matters
okay so buy it and help us support i
don't know what the next
daddy osmond i don't know oh yeah buddy
just help me buy
pay for donny osmond can i sing with
donnie no it's my wedding
yeah sing with donnie no no no
can we do a vlog with donnie his show is
opening in vegas august 31st
he's coming back solo it's the first
time in four years that he's been back
by himself
can we go literally zoned out what can
we do can we do a frenemies vlog with
donnie osmond in vegas
if i can sing with him at your wedding
no how about in the vlog you can sing
can i do can mean ila do a like uh renew
our vows after you
no i don't think so i'm just kidding i'm
just trying to [ __ ] up your wedding you
should
oh my god you should renew can either
wear a wedding dress
yeah that is the vibe everyone's wearing
white she can wear her wedding dress
yeah a straight up
wedding but when my friend texted me the
other day is like can i wear my body or
something yeah
that's weird yeah if your friend shows
up in a wedding dress she's weird
with peace in the world everyone's
wearing the girls have to wear white i
thought you're supposed to make your
bridesmaids dress as ugly as possible
no they're going to be booze they're
going to be still like putrid green
dress no it's going to be white silk
it's going to it's going to be dope
because my my dress is so extravagant
and so it's so cool people are like
whoa damn i'm i feel honored that i'm
invited to this it's gonna be quite an
event of course
you're the whole reason that we're
getting married if it wasn't for you
yeah so
let me sing with donnie can i officiate
the wedding
no we don't
no but you said you said on the episode
where we talked about moses you said
uh he'll want to [ __ ] you but not want
to marry you and now did i say that yes
oh that was rude to me well i'm not
going to say that you're wrong there's
so many clips of it on tic tac
i said you moses would want to [ __ ] you
yeah marry you didn't you say that
yeah he'll you know he'll definitely
he's kind of like he'll we could
probably [ __ ] he's like yeah
he'll probably find a [ __ ] you but not
marry you no
proven wrong that was mean it's all over
yeah you weren't mean i was talking no
but not a bad way i was mean too but the
producer i was talking to today she's
like you know i was like but you know
what the difference is now you have
grown there is so much growth from you
people always talk about my girl because
i'm crazy and all
aloud but your growth is also really
good
a little bit so thank you to trish uh
thank i just thanked you
oh okay got you okay okay so can i be
the flower girl
no how can i make this about me
[Laughter]
can i can i can i uh skydive during the
ceremony
no okay all right we're indoors so okay
meme game meme game all right let's do
the meme game me me me me me me
all right ian bring out ian bring out
the [ __ ]
[Laughter]
oh thank you ian he said ian said it's
just a link on your computer
i don't think we'll have time for that
one but that's good for next i was a
superhero on stanley show who wants to
be a superhero as miss limelight oh i
never even explained what this was the
uh
adrian kickback so anyway everyone on
tick tock came over to huntington beach
just for like a meme
they're like oh we're going to adrian's
kickback and it turned into like a riot
actually yeah there was like rioters
there and like riot police came out
it was like a whole show oh is that why
we're not seeing what we're doing
tomorrow because there might be a riot
probably because you're ready
just had ethan we're a duo on this one
yeah i wish dan's right we shouldn't say
what it is
okay can we cook at benny hannah too you
want to see some footage
can we be bunny hannah chefs oh just
that would be fun to cook for but like
they don't know
and we're just like the worst chefs like
eggs flying everywhere i'd be a good job
but okay
no you wouldn't go off king you you can
do egg tricks excuse me yes i've done it
before i've been able to do [ __ ]
i have a vlog that's a bunny unless it's
drowning in butter you can't cook it
that's how you beat me i'm still bitter
what
i did beat you you're right damn so
here's what it turned into
i love butter and here's the riot police
dispersing crowds it was like a whole
[ __ ] show bro
adrian adrian had a hell of a kickback
dude
they're stomping cars flipping cars
funny it's funny though yeah yeah it's a
little scary except for the writing
yeah but for all this dude was just
trying to have a little get together
from hamilton like people are rioting
people in france no no no no if you give
them a chance it's from hamilton you
know
yeah that was about adrian's kickback
incidentally
anyway that's it let's do the meme game
let's do the meme game okay so here's
how it works
i am going to show you a meme without a
template
first you're going to try to guess
you're a meme without attempting and
what is it
oh i can't believe you said that about
me thank you dan
you got it
[Laughter]
okay so the first one is arthur's fist
i've seen it oh i want to thank philip
and know your meme for helping us put
this together
wait that's the game he's he's the guy
creating know your meme no he has the
website know your man
he just works there oh he works there
but yeah he reached out
there's fists so what do you think this
is used to convey
anger yes that's it okay really i mean
right
but the funny thing is that is that a
meme that's like literal the funny thing
is that it's from
arthur the children's show well anyway
he's
just the sweet guy in the show and
apparently the author of the show got
really upset that people were using it
in this world oh my god makes it even
funnier people are
so crazy wait what was he doing in the
show i watched the clip i think he was
actually angry in the show so
people can be angry that's a human
emotion like
yeah he's ready to throw down he he he
he's practicing
domestic abuse no he's right he's right
he's not kidding
actually dead ass all off the cliff
yeah it's like that means you can't lie
i'm like i literally thought oh my god
can you pull the clip that ass stop
deadass the clip
that triggers me you said it i know and
i got triggered i went backwards
david be like i'm gonna turn your ass
into
debt i'm gonna try because he tries to
kill all his friends i'm gonna try to
turn your ass in the dead ass
i'm gonna turn you from an alive ass to
a dead
[Laughter]
here's the clip geez i can't breathe
here's the clip okay yeah when i watched
this i was like why is he mad
he was actually just angry that's him
what is he a little beaver or what
oh no what did i use this clip is kind
of iconic he slaps the [ __ ] out of his
sister
actually they're just kids okay but
why are you good boy she was [ __ ]
around
she wasn't listening to headquarters
sound barrier broken
what's my next mission general
you have to slap this [ __ ] out of here
he's having a good time right now
[Music]
did you even read the directions it
didn't
one to the kisser bro why is the
creator getting angry you literally
showed domestic abuse and breeding
brother and sister
he brought it down he brought the
thunder you saw the clouds started going
gray and [ __ ] so he's literally angry
why is she mad that that's the meme but
it's angry
she should be angry if he's like fisting
somebody you know like in a sexual way
okay i get that he's five but like if
he's angry and he's angry in the show
what's the problem i'm [ __ ] safe
fisting sexually how's that you don't
know what fisting is
i know what fisting is but i don't see
how you draw that from this cause he's
making a fist and i get it
i don't is that how you fist people you
go yeah one shot
see how much your knuckles can get up
there what's the deepest someone's been
in you
i i haven't been fisted okay i'll just
ask you okay sorry
just the candles i thought you might i'm
sorry stop
maybe bring that up next time you see my
mother be like did you ever get fisted
how many fists do you get on your ass
okay fair enough whatever all right so
make a
make a um so what what do you make i'm
so angry
so make a caption my minds i'm so angry
just i'm so angry
i what else would it be okay what was
your caption
i'm so angry and then mine is
did you do you know this one when you're
dumb [ __ ] sister
no i'm kidding well it's literal i guess
literally yeah so
that's fine um it would be let's see um
i came up with mine in a second i knew
it right away
when the chicken wings arrive without
ranch
food that doesn't even make any sense
okay what do you mean
when the chicken wings arrive without
ranch it's like you make a fist you're
angry
yeah i'm a break [ __ ] that's the meme um
all right so here let me show you some
examples
what we eating for dinner food me don't
get it
me waiting for the water to boil
oh okay well they put some pasta i
didn't know we could put props into his
hand
i guess that's an evolutionary name well
i can put a prop in his hand
when you offer somebody food and they
say yeah oh
cause you didn't want to share it so
don't offer it in the first place dummy
then you're just being polite if you
don't want to share don't offer it
um why can't i zoom out now dan this is
so cursed
i can't zoom out no i literally can't
zoom out
so stupid um
when they assume everyone is
right-handed okay they flipped it
yeah well i don't like this meme doesn't
mean it's stupid so we don't like this
meme
let's pull up the means are you racist
against aardvarks
oh my god
you guys have discord i'll be in that
discord so here's trisha's meme
wow oh my god i'm so angry
can i post that how do i get that copy
of that that's something i'll email it
to you
just say new frenemies yeah that's cute
so that's tricia that looks dope it
looks like a real one what if ian just
makes all the memes of the internet
tim because that looks like it that
looks like that font
well there's yeah that's crazy i know so
wait
okay so okay oh and then here's here's
daddy ethan's
no too long too many words when the
chicken wings arrive without ranch way
too many words
don't understand it okay so dan's
laughing go ahead
guys i mean clearly trisha's doesn't
even attempt
well like most of trisha's memes hers
has this like
kind of anti-humor thing to it where
it's it's so literal that it's funny
um i i do like yours though ethan i
think i'll help you
it's like me asking moses
you cannot
[Laughter]
moses has never crossed you
okay i don't need an explanation we
don't like sauce so we don't really
moses says mine bro are you really doing
mental gymnastics
what does your preference for salt have
to do with the quality of the meat
we don't eat ranch with the chicken
wings all right just give an answer
moses go ahead i dare you
i'm so angry okay
okay ian your vote
he said he's owning tricia so that
that's true yeah but
ian also like i think ian hates
i can't me that i think he does
you have to there's legitimate humor in
there
it's okay because you can feel it when
you see the hand you can feel it
moses that's the mean yeah you don't
need
the caption all right and not everything
needs to be a fight why are we talking
about trisha
i knew you were gonna win because it's
just such a [ __ ] but thank you dan
for at least not
thank you dan for being honest what a
pull-up book can you do a poll can you
do polls on youtube still or is that
like an old thing remember you used to
be able to do polls
he always would do polls he's like
here's a poll i think in the community
the community posts you can do polls
still yeah we can do a poll
we are a philip it's probably better to
just do it or audience interaction
keep leave your thoughts in the comments
no yeah he's like
you know what i just hear your thoughts
my thing is i don't want your thoughts
keep your thoughts to yourself no
comments
please do me a favor don't leave a
[ __ ] comment
and watch it enjoy it i don't want to
know what you thought you can leave a
comment for me
only if it's nice good luck i'm just
saying people in the comments are mean
that's why i say
people were turning on me a little last
week i'm sorry i apologize i'm an
ignorant dumbass
not good enough all right next one
what can i do the next one is called
distracted boyfriend
oh i love this i love it already okay um
okay i've seen it honestly you've seen
this yeah this one's really popular
i don't get these because there's so
many parts to this now the background i
think the background of this is that
it's just
one of those really corny stock photos
yeah yeah for sure i did stock photo
work
that uh just picked up so what do you
think this is meant to
convey i've seen these and i really
don't quite understand them i know
there's three parts to them
so i would can i just do it now so red
shirt
is palestine israel america okay
is that good oh that's it yeah okay i
think that was good
palestine israel america
there's three parts and it's all on the
red sh
no no okay palestine israel america
wait which one is who's the guy which
one is israel he's blue like the flag so
she's palestine the guy's israel and the
blues america yeah
is that right i think that's pretty good
i think it makes i mean i see what
you're doing
right so palestine so israel wants
palestine
and america is like eh but israel well
america does support israel pretty
pretty i don't know the logistics i went
by okay
okay plague flag i'm not sure if it
makes sense logistically but
all right all right all right cool you
know i don't know okay here i go here i
go
okay okay okay here we go trisha's memes
moses me
i get that one oh i think you're gonna
win i'd better [ __ ] win but i have
political humor
mine is so much better than yours
got it all right well let's take a vote
moses come see your ass down
he can't see all right all right all
right
pissed at him oh my god he goes well i
don't like sauce
no we don't like sauce all of a sudden
moses doesn't like sausage i've never
tasted wrench
all right you've got so let's pull them
off that's not fair you use me and your
meme
you can use whatever you want in your
man but i am a meme you can't use a meme
and a meme you know what i mean
here's trisha's okay i think that's
pretty good palestine
israel america no no i don't think so i
think i don't know what i'm talking
about i just kind of like
it's i don't think it's three entities
you know okay so here's trisha's
kind of makes sense but not really i'll
take it
i was i was being political too you know
so you don't even have to be funny
though people go oh she's
this is a humor okay yeah let's not try
okay
oh my god okay now here's a real meme
okay this was good because i get it i
got it right away this is memes
moses ethan come on that's funny moses
i agree that's a vote for me yes thank
you
i mean finally that's the first time
moses ever voted for me for anything
we've ever competed
oh name one when have you ever voted for
me for anything moses well i was only
asked about the food and she was
superior we did well there was something
else we did too i think just the food
cake the cake the cake yeah no that
looks scary no
so you got the vote you look scary your
birthday's coming up though
i'm already on the ropes you go you look
scary to me oh i don't know i just say
stuff like that i just repeat what
people say
what did i do i don't know i just say
things i don't know i was thinking about
your birthday i got your present
so it's coming up june 24th right mm-hmm
i'm so excited for it so we're gonna
celebration 21st here in frenemies
sounds great to me okay i'm excited i'm
excited for you okay
gemini next week we've got oh you know
what's fun
theodore's birthday his second birthday
is coming up in june
and we're going to disneyland next week
that's exciting it's gonna be so fun
yeah he'll love that he's gonna be like
oh
cause he's excited about everything he's
like yeah you know that's gonna be
something like
like blue hair he's like blue you know
he's so that's cool i wish i was a kid i
just got excited about like colors
that's a dope like so happy everything's
fun he is always happy
and i'm sitting there all depressed and
sad and anxious and i'm like i'm like
you're not like that though around him
you're always happy you're always like
ah let's go play you're very active like
i feel like i want to be an active mom
because i'm kind of fat so i feel like i
just said go play but you're very active
with him
i try to be as as as possible yeah they
say kids are the best weight loss so
that's true he's a [ __ ] animal all
right so distracted boyfriend we're 1-1
i love this i love this game whoever
came up with a good job i believe it was
ian's idea
yeah ian is the best i mean honestly
he's like is he invited to your wedding
yeah for sure is he getting a box yeah
for sure getting a box
is that getting a box uh who yeah
and i oop that was you right now
i love ap but i think we just you know i
don't know okay this is classic
this is one of the most classical
everyone can come share right now this
is the drake meme
he is this is hotline bling no no okay
so
give me he likes bbw though
so bb so go ahead with the man but i
like my girls thick
not just kind of fine eat her out call
that one and dine
i just know his lyrics about fat girls
because i know he likes fat girls um
fat porn star specifically so if i was
single drake i'd be right here but i'm
not so
find another fat porn star okay um this
one is
oh oh i got it i got it um
porn stars under size 12 porn stars bbw
there you go all right do we know that
about drake
uh can you continue yeah confirm it i
know about him trust me i know about
everyone liking fat girls i'm on it
every guy who likes fat girls you're
like track them hugh grant too oh
yeah oh not hugh jackman who jackman has
a
he's a huge wife but we love huge i'm a
huge girl bbw yeah huge
jack jackson loves it hugh i'm trying to
think about that
huge jack huge ass man
okay by that logic you would be his type
then you're a huge ass man
all right mine would be i want to do
another trisha meme one
no you cannot use me as your meme i'm
kidding okay let's see here
okay how about this one you're gonna
hate it oh it's you're not gonna like
this one
i'll tell you what i was thinking the
top is sad boy 2005
and the bottom is teddy fresh oh well
that's laughs it's a merch war
it's a joke i know it's just a joke i'm
sorry
i'm not doing that one i hope hila
yelled at you okay wait here i've got
one
i've got one whatever um
okay here you're gonna like this one
h3 podcast on the top frenemies on the
bottom
oh okay kind of you know literally
you started h3 it's your brand that's
your thing yeah
that's where all the people are yeah and
still yeah you hear
i'm just making a joke is it not good i
would say like impulsive in front of me
oh that's we don't need a [ __ ] on age
three i gotta do better that's
embarrassing maybe off the rails
and frenemies okay wait let me start
over okay
maybe solo ethan ethan with a female
co-host
non-binary whatever all of it they them
which by the way can i say non-binary
means gender fluid i switch genders a
lot even he him like sometimes moses
refers to me to see him just fyi we are
genderfluid
just saying i don't have a good one
okay how about this um
i'm not going to get a good one out of
this oh you have to
you were good those were good those were
good just go with whatever everybody had
it frenemies at the bottom
whatever is at the top whatever's at the
top every other podcast
you know exactly yeah i mean do you want
to get phil defranco shout out
maybe like skinny legend something like
being a skinny legend
oh phil defranco is a coward on the top
skinny legend on the bottom
power like an apology yeah yeah all
right let's go with the phil defranco
apology
the top is philip defranco's a coward we
don't like that we don't say that
yeah philip defranco skinny on the
bottom
we love that about him
that's good i like that thank you hey i
did i did take a little help from you i
think but it was more of a i'm so good
at memes aren't i i'm thinking i'm
pretty good at them i'm pretty good
i guess if you don't care about like uh
actually doing the music no because
they're like tick tocks to me like every
time i do like a caption i feel like my
cash on tick tock's kind of vr it you
know what i mean
oh okay who's blowing up just my phone
i love looking at who's texting people
it's my favorite thing to do
here you want to see yeah you can't
psych
notification
my phone gets lost i want people like
reading my [ __ ] you can read mine
because the thing is like if you lose
your phone
then if they try to like whatever
okay here we go we got memes on deck
memes on deck
stacks on deck all right trisha coming
through with this
oh this is my don't put that on me
philip defranco's a coward
i like that i get it yeah phil
defranco's a skinny legend
yes i hate memes like these are not
funny when people come up with like even
the hand gestures like it's this
whatever
it's funny who does that who has that
time
what's the time it's a screenshot like a
shot from a music video like
i mean i had a desktop for five years
and that's pretty much all i did you
was just [ __ ] that's all right that
does it says a lot yeah i sat there for
i didn't have
i'm still winning you on this meme
where's my meme you didn't put my meme
up there
i'm waiting for you okay
like waiting for you and he's like it's
there uh okay so here's yours
porn star under 12 porn star bbw i think
mine's good
vote or what not only do i have to vote
for tricia on that but that's
because of the meta commentary that's
like one of the best drake memes i've
ever
seen actually because it's about drake
yeah no that's legitimately really good
i try and do the correlation
oh everyone else anyone i agree with dan
about it it is it is him it's he's a
drake
yeah okay thank you okay moses
yours is funny i i will say but i was
going to vote for yours when it was
friend of mine this is kind of an
all-timer drake meme right here
change on him liar you changed it on me
[Laughter]
so you sabotaged me that was my original
one i think you made me feel bad about
it
i was going to pose for it i was you
made me feel bad about it
and then i changed
is that a thing are you just swimming oh
ian you didn't vote but it doesn't
matter
no it matters
because you won but ian
[Laughter]
his name is teams oh i've never seen
this one ever okay so
never definitely james what did she oh
it was like the the alpha and the beta
is that what i don't know go ahead give
it a caption um
i would say left joe rogan
ethan klein wow i don't know i don't
know what it means so
i'm just assuming because he's buff and
you're like a bat i don't know
brutal isn't me i don't know i don't
know this meme i really don't know the
meme but
um i'm assuming it's that kind of thing
okay i'm gonna have to hit back at you
you just said
your friday show said he was alpha or
whatever i don't know when he listed it
okay how about this oh no on the left
frenemies
on the right the dish would trip
of me yeah do it you brought it there
you could do well thanks for the
district promo i'll go check it out it's
still up on youtube
yeah undiscontinued that's why i would
never work with them by the way because
nobody can cancel us no could be like
your shows
you know what's so crazy because i know
other podcasts they have that get like a
hundred views like literally a hundred
views a hundred downloads
i think they just make sas friends with
shane you know because i really i don't
think podcasts get canceled like they'll
give you three cents you know and i was
doing good so i think they just eat
whatever
it's okay because you contacted me right
after i got canceled yeah i'll take it
this is great my background by the way i
feel like you took inspiration from the
district
because it used to be this background so
i feel like it's a little bit what are
you talking about you're rewriting
history
this is literally the dishwasher's
background was it yes it was painted on
my walls i was like hardcore so all
right
i don't know i think that was i think
that was intentionally take it easy
okay ethan didn't even know he's like
what take it easy
all right so here's trisha's love it
meme shaming joe rogan
ethan klein i love it i'll be proud to
post that on my instagram
yeah it's just super insulting but is it
wait what is the meme like just
someone's really strong
he's an alpha and i'm a beta wait really
yeah
that's so dumb i hate alpha beta yeah
well you just played right into the
stereotype
but who wants to be alpha
all right my did i skip the last one
yeah
you did my dad at 17
darling i'm home now how are the kids me
at 17th damn i wish i were a cute enemy
oh you were supposed to put like
captions you should told me this but i
didn't know you you didn't even put a
caption with yours you could put caption
artist then i made timeless masterpiece
now and i'm a model to every
beginner artist artist now i taped a
banana on this wall
i don't like this meme it's not funny
and also they're adding props
we didn't get props oh trisha's 11 year
long career as a living meme and troll
just his ability to understand memes
i like it because it says my name i like
anybody who gives me credit by the way
it's 14 years i've been on youtube i
started in 2006
i'm 15. it's 15 years yeah get her okay
calm down
like it or not i'm an og i'm longer than
phil defranco 15 years
thank you franco but i don't know who's
been on but who else who else has been
longer than us me and phillip
oh geez without taking breaks people are
like on hiatus they take a break
posting every day for 15 years
so here's mine by the way which i did
not show and i think uh you may want to
consider
for your consideration for your consider
frenemies the dishwasher
i think it's funny but it's a little too
niche i don't think anyone knows what
the distribution is you know what i mean
no offense
it was your podcast yeah with peace and
love no they got
yeah but hey all right let's take a vote
uh i'm gonna go with ethan's this time
thank you that one made me laugh
well you know notoriety i'll take it
frenemies is poppin
well you should be happy too you like
mine thank you
you should be happy my two ones that
have won were all about you
[Laughter]
vote should be in the comments let us
know who won the meme competition right
score is uh two to two now oh
here we go this is him feel old yet okay
so
you feel old yeah wait there's no to
empty temp wait
how do i present this one
okay okay so i guess this is oh
don't do you feel old yet where it's
like a before and after so here's james
charles
remember james this is him now feel old
yet
damn it's kind of crazy he was cruising
around in that makeup
well it was a flashback he has a lot of
powder on his face when you powder it
flashes that way
but like damn you gotta plan your
flashbacks better yeah well that's why
they call it flashback mary
i don't know this meme that well so i'm
not really sure well it looks just like
him we'll grab this or whatever this
um i don't know what that is either so
it's like weird this is the kid from
home alone this is him now feel old yet
but that's two different people that's
something called calculating very true
observation so what's a meme i guess
that they look
you change into someone else it looks
similar
it's the joke it's a joke
remember peter pan this is him now feel
old yet
hmm i don't get it it's kind of meadow
like he does because he doesn't age
okay oh i got it i gotta go i got one i
got one okay remember the chocolate cake
kid from
matilda this is him now feel old yes
that's why i wanna cosplay
i want to be brucy with the chocolate
cake bruce brucey and he's always
talking like my blood sweat and tears
went into this cake
i love him can we cosplay as him this is
james charles feel old yet kind of the
same thing monsters inc
okay so just a different meme okay i got
it i got it same man i'm ready
okay so now how do we do this do we just
pick two random images
ian yeah if you want okay
go ahead hey they both came over to me
let's give them
go ahead pick two and pick two things
okay
i'm gonna go with the peter pan and
michael jackson
right bro that's kind of [ __ ] up
because a lot of people say peter pan is
like a
pedo you've euphemism right okay so
you're
you actually are on my side with michael
i thought you were a michael apology he
lived in neverland
you know what i mean he dead wait so do
you think michael did it or not i think
he died
do you think he did it oh did what wait
michael's alive
michael jackson died oh he died do you
think michael jackson did it
did what you know oh
i believe the victims yeah me too okay
oh hashtag me too
so i think it's a good meme okay so
okay and then here i'll do one i don't
know this isn't weird i don't know
okay and then mine will be um you
remember that interview goes i'm peter
pan and he's like no michael jackson
goes no i'm peter pan he said it was
martin bashir you don't remember that
interview i do remember that he was in
trees
yeah that was cool you're looking like
peter pan right now yeah
i think that's a good meme okay jesus
we'll just pull that out of your ass
i'm so good at these um
okay left one left one is is um
jesus christ right one is moses
are you saying he looks old this is
jesus christ feel old yet
oh my god jesus is eternal so i don't
know what that means whole game
actually jesus didn't die the jesus the
human was it like this
look as unattractive as possible
match my energy yeah i'm gonna match the
energy oh my god how do you get your leg
up okay skinny holy [ __ ]
can you get your legs off you can let's
see it's hard
let me see those legs okay you know
what's crazy or
kind of funny i was sitting i was
putting um theodore to sleep last night
and he dropped a bottle behind his crib
so i was sitting like this in the
rocking chair
and i leaned back to get the bottle and
i felt this huge rocket jar and i fell
and theodore was like chair chair chair
he's gotta oh was he scared
yeah he thought that's when i say moses
can you help me i'm fat
moses can you help me i'm fat it works
he's the skinny one so he'll run to get
if i leave something in the house he'll
run upstairs to get it he'll oh yeah
i'll go up and get it
all right so we're waiting for the memes
to come in game generator
meme ian's in the background crunching
the numbers
oh because you have to find the picture
this one doesn't have like a set
wait did i take the lead dan or is it
tied it's time it's tied okay
i forgot what yours was oh moses and
jesus yeah it doesn't make sense because
you're saying moses looks old
yeah older than jesus he's frightened
but jesus must have died he must have
been like 20 years 33 my
age oh he was 33. yeah jesus lived a
good long life
god you're stupid how did you not know i
didn't know jesus lived 33 how they know
that
his whole story was 29 to 33 yeah you
know 33 it's like okay boring age fun
fact
be cool if he died at 20. that's the
only year as moses played jesus when he
was 29-33 he retired at 33 cause he
didn't want to play jesus any older than
he was fun fact about moses hockman
he stopped at 33 for accuracy
oh really yeah then my so then i'm my
meme is right
yeah i'm 10 years old you don't want to
but moses but so tell me the truth did
jesus die or not is he dead or not
he grows from the dead so is he so he's
alive
he's alive god's not dead he's surely
alive
so here you are we are right before you
oh michael jackson is dead if
jesus was brought back to life then
surely he's among us
yeah he's among us god was one of
us he's not he's better
he's godson oh jesus or god
what if god was one of us when are jesus
they say jesus and god and the holy
ghost are all the same thing it's like
bro what the [ __ ] you can't keep your
[ __ ] together they're not the same thing
they see the holy
amen all right here's oh he ended some
work on this
okay ian's kind of doing work for you
over here oh wow
that looks good okay so remember peter
pan this is him now feel old yet
okay but peter pan is not supposed to
age
huh peter pan does not age this meme is
not accurate
but he's an orthopedo
so when he stops when he stops r
worrying kids he ages
he lives in neverland michael admitted
to being peter pan
proof is in the pudding oh you really
have to put it that way the pudding
i like pudding yeah michael jackson
likes pudding too
huh i don't get the is it euphemism yeah
i thought are you kind of
crossing the with the bill cosby thing
oh
pudding it's like brown and gooey and i
was like what yeah
i know i watched the documentary he was
into their he was into like
the pudding hole pudding is a euphemism
for something because on dinner for
schmucks they say that like eat my
pudding remember zach galifianakis and
steve crowley's like say eat my pudding
i'll let you eat my pudding i don't know
i don't like pudding i don't like zac
elephants
why i don't like i don't know i don't
know anything about him actually
hater apologies i was so positive but
i'm getting hungry thank you angry
i'm super hungry all right so so i think
this is oh
okay this is a good one remember jesus
this is him now feel old yet
looks good to me ah
i like it because it has my moves in it
what little we think i like how he looks
sad too moses like damn my age
i was supposed to be immortal i don't
know which picture he used
it's good damn i got a raw deal
damn this is a good one too it's a hard
one
all right dan go ahead um
i i can't really decide between these
two they're about they're about equal
it's kind of a point off for me oh my
god
uh super technically we because you
didn't actually anyways you know i paid
the logistics
well you get a little extra from front
of me you have to pay the crew so we pay
them
for mondays you did tell me that oh so i
pay them too
from our earnings interesting
i pay you dan you give extra money to
yourself so we can pay the crew
that was the thing yeah but they don't
just work for your show i mean
we're taking it out of our show i give
an extra five percent out of my
check for something yeah for us doing
every [ __ ] the highlights are for
everything what's the extra five oh it's
all it's all for everything anyways we
don't need to get into that you show up
we do everything we we pay then okay
trisha payzio also did because i don't
give
up i'll sign a check if that's all i'll
sign it you can't sign [ __ ]
i'll sign it i'm sorry in front of me um
i guess i'm gonna i'm gonna go with
ethan's i think uh
of course of course i'm always accused
of being on your side well now
i'm trying to be impartial here i'm
trying to be impartial listen it's a
meme yours doesn't even make sense
you're using people in the room i could
use people in the room too
okay moses don't it's just it's got you
in it
well not because of that but i do think
it's a good meme
[Music]
thank you i can't wait for the comments
big treasure one ethan
he throws a pity party and everyone
votes for him dude the comments are
literally always like ethan
like on the cake one did you see the
comments
with peace and love no okay whatever
thank you moses you just dispelled i
thought you were biased but that proves
me wrong so thank you oh my god
ian you have an unbiased heart thank you
vote
no you're the pity vote you're the ones
like come on three two come on
ethan's in the lead i didn't think this
would be an event i could win to be
totally honest with you i thought you
would sweep it
with all your [ __ ] titles whatever i
win for sure so so it's two to three
right now in ethan's favor um
i think we probably with the pace we're
doing only have time for one maybe two
more so we should
let's let's slam okay so this is i
remember when this
meme hit the market i was that was a
long time ago this one this is an
ancient meme now
i guess everyone was like this guy looks
like the biggest douche ever i've never
seen this in my life
really no it's man it was so what is a
scumbag what did he do
it's like he looks like that friend
who's just a bit giant douche like here
i'll read some captions maybe i'll help
you
thanks for the smallest images ever
um go to high school parties 25 years
old
yo dawg let me hit that blunt has the
[ __ ] flu
no drive slowly in the left lane speeds
up when you try to pass him
oh okay you buy the liquor i'll buy the
beer
case of natty light
oh wow this is next level stay safe
everyone take
precautions is at the saddle ranch every
single night is that a kova joke
yes okay joke so there you have it
scumbag
steve ladies and gentlemen
scumbag this is hard why is the hat
so big it looks photoshopped is that
real i don't get why he's a scumbag
why'd that poor guy have to be the
scumbag he's just wearing a fur coat
he just looks like that dude in high
school who's a douche you know he looks
like he
had it hard you're like it's just
parents i don't have a lot of people
feeling bad for scumbag steve
i don't like that he got scumbags steve
maybe scuba steve or something you know
scuba steve what's scuba big daddy all
right
you got a caption um james charles on
top
and snapchat on the bottom
i don't get it but it's kind of cool do
she james charles at the top
is it good i guess maybe because it's
james like what up snapchat i'm a
[ __ ] i'm gonna predict prey on all
the underage kids here
maybe crystalia
his podcast audience
interesting maybe
maybe just title
chris hanson i'm going with that just
chris hanson
interesting okay that's my final answer
that's hard interesting okay where am i
where's my head at
don't steal one of mine i just gave you
three
i gave you three we're gonna put vape
nation put mine change mine to vape
nation i'm changing it to that
that's scumbag steve vape nation and
chris hanson wait so what's your name
vape nation just vape nation yeah that's
you that's you on vape nation
okay i think chris hanson was better
i don't get chris hanson i get vape
nation douchey
okay vape nation looks like the bully in
high school
vape nationality
uh i've got something percolating i need
food
i should have brought a little snack i
know my energy is hot
this morning all i had was um lemon well
this is what i do in during the weekdays
i just have lemon juice
and like a vegetable smoothie in the
morning but that's
that's my breakfast yeah yeah
it's not good you should get a little
something well that's part of my diet
and then i eat after the show
okay the problem is i want to eat
something [ __ ] brutal you don't have
to eat something brutal just eat a
little something so you don't get so
hungry like what are you going to go eat
well we are celebrating myself boys and
we're doing we're going to go eat
something brutal
because we're celebrating what are you
eating you're always celebrating
monday's our happy day it is our happy
day
celebrating i want to celebrate
what are you celebrating being a fat
[ __ ] and wanting to eat something
monstrous
i thought friday was your uh friday baby
friday baby was your
cheat day yeah would you eat i ordered a
burger but it was sucked
it was really disappointing and i got
fries with garlic and cheddar
cheese and it was like horrible we don't
like take out i can make those free
fresh i'm really good at cooking burgers
yummy cookie burger i love that
i'm really good at it i butter the
butter the bun i butter the bun and make
it crispy
you ever just hold your fat i do that i
do my food but i hold that because it's
warm
like in the genitals you hold your gents
yeah because it's
warm yeah the gents feels good down
there
did you come up with okay um
okay buzz
uh okay david dobrik
inviting you in a vlog
and then at the bottom smashes your face
into an excavator
okay that's good right okay dan likes
it maybe we should just put
reddit you want to change yours again no
we're going to keep
we're keeping vape nation yeah from you
oh wow there's a company he had already
made
actually three oh my god three yeah
there we go okay
all right so here's all of trish as well
i don't need to show you it's one says
uh i mean they're all i thought this was
that one snapchat yeah this was your
probably your strongest no i don't know
what that means but you changed your
you changed it okay but
to so here let me show you chris you
want the vape nation
but no one knows what that is so that's
a little too neat everybody knows what
vape is stopped but it's all my most
popular video
it's like the dish with trish compared
it you know what i mean there's like a
little niche you have to know what it's
like 30 million views
six years ago okay i'm kidding
vape nation that's yours yeah not sure i
get it
are you just saying i'm a dude yeah he
laughed out loud
there's another one that is just doesn't
make any sense
literally it's douche okay you're
calling me a douche
no i'm calling your vape nation
character okay david dobrik inviting you
to vlog smash his face into an exercise
that's the real scumbag steve thing i
feel like that one
actually fits the traditional uh format
pretty much and it has the ss like the
dd the dave dobrik ss comic steve
david dobrik right what i didn't
understand that
pizza do you want pizza you remember
he's gonna have a weekend pizza
oh he was gonna have a pizza shop called
doe bricks
he was yeah [ __ ] is trying to do
everything it's like
chill just for focus we should go
mukbang at doe brooks when it opens look
at some dough brooks pizza
you know what cp also stands for
no idea cp not that he's into it but
james charles
is like a slice james charles might like
a slice of sea
wait what's cp where did you even think
of that okay but what made you think of
that that's what
because you were talking about pizza
and then we're talking about james
charles cheese pizza
cp oh okay okay
[Music]
all right let's let's vote this is our
last one
go ahead dan um
[Music]
yeah this dobrick one got me pretty good
thank you that's pretty good oh my god
i mean you really just wrote vape nation
don't be too old that was good it was a
little low effort
it was a little low effort i'm low
effort because i have no food in my
belly
i need to bring a snack for halfway
through because we take pee breaks and
then you guys you know we're gonna take
a lot of breaks i need to take a little
snack break
moses uh trisha is funny okay
yeah always he didn't want to go too
against the uh no
yeah and i know you don't want to rock
the boat too hard you should be mad i'm
getting hungry
stop it oh my god i do not
uh i'm
respects me nerds okay so that means
that i win four to two
what do you win i don't know nothing
finally won something at least
wow is that the first contest you've won
on that feels frankly
hollow sad no i appreciate
congratulations
i'm proud of you i'll give you a
toothbrush over there they're not a
sponsor today but you can have that one
thank you you're welcome all right you
want something i should get you
something on my purse
well guys get excited because we're
shooting a vlog tomorrow i feel like our
vlogs are way more than vlogs
a vlog it's like we have a cool plan for
tomorrow it's gonna be super fun
and i'm hoping to have it out for you
guys on thursday i'll give you this
some small change four dollars what did
i win four bucks
[Applause]
[Laughter]
thank you thank you you are very good
thanks for your effort thank you i'll
dip the pizza guy
yeah okay all right so thanks for
watching
oh wait we have a video comes out on
thursday so uh maybe out on the weekend
i don't know
when no one's watching we'll put it on a
saturday night again right who doesn't
watch oh well saturday night's not the
best time
right right boxing matches are on
saturday night
people still watch it
thanks for watching guys we'll see you
on our vlog and next week you know what
it is frenemies 24 7. we never stopped
sadboy 2005.
separately.com teddyfresh teddyfresh.com
teddyfresh.com
but spy everything on sad boy 2005 and
then go to teddy fred
yeah yeah but make sure it's all sold
out for us on sad boys yeah yeah
it'll it will be okay that's just gonna
fly off the show ah i think
all right thank you guys
[Music]
you